Have you ever tried BBQ on BBQ? Picture this. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky barbecue glaze and topped with a creamy barbecue sauce. Can't picture it? Well you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In mid-2004 Australian real estate group LJ Hooker posted a for sale sign on the front lawn of a vacant address in North Ride, a cosmopolitan suburb in northwestern Sydney. The modern two-story home had been constructed four years prior at Sandy Brick veneer as pristine as the day it was built. Its windowed facade overlooked the leafy residential strip of Collins Street, a small quiet thoroughfare lined with similar medium sized family homes. The four bedroom three bathroom property was spacious though homely and boasted a double garage with an adjoining carport. A pathway led from the smooth concrete driveway to the front door, framing the manicured lawn. The entrance, foyer and hallway granted access to a study, laundry, lounge, dining area and kitchen, which overlooked a small grassy courtyard framed by a sunlit garden bed. A curved wooden staircase led to the upper floor where the four bedrooms were located, including a master with ensuite.
你尝过烧烤味上的烧烤吗？设想一下：新鲜出炉、外脆里嫩的调味鸡肉，裹上一层烟熏烧烤釉，上面再铺上一层浓郁的烧烤酱。想象不出来？没关系，你现在就可以去蒂姆餐厅品尝。限时推出我们全新的烧烤脆皮鸡饭碗和卷饼。我们的节目涉及严重且通常令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您手机应用上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。2004年中期，澳大利亚房地产集团LJ霍克（LJ Hooker）在悉尼西北部大都会郊区莱德北区（North Ryde）一处空置地址的前草坪上竖起了一块“出售”告示牌。这座现代化的两层住宅建于四年前，红砖贴面依然像建造当天那样崭新。它带窗户的正面俯瞰着柯林斯街（Collins Street）绿树成荫的住宅区，这是一条安静的小马路，两旁排列着类似的中型家庭住宅。这座四居室三卫的物业宽敞而温馨，拥有一个带相连车棚的双车库。一条小路从平坦的混凝土车道通往正门，衬托出修剪整齐的草坪。入口、门厅和走廊通向书房、洗衣房、起居室、用餐区和厨房，厨房俯瞰着一个阳光充足的花园床环绕的小草坪庭院。一处弧形木质楼梯通往二楼，四间卧室都在那里，其中包括一间带套内浴室的主卧。
The property presented ample opportunity for a young family wishing to capitalise on the superb location. North Ride is nestled on the banks of Langcoe River and enclosed coastal inlet that joins Parramatta River to form an arm of the iconic Sydney Harbour. Only 15 kilometres from Sydney's central business district, North Ride is popular with professionals and families alike, attracted by the strong community spirit and abundance of schools, parklands, transport services and shopping districts. The stately Collins Street property caught the eye of the Lynn family, Taiwanese immigrants looking to settle in the area. The lins were shown through the house by LJ Hooker real estate agents on three separate occasions. Each time they admired the freshly painted green coloured walls, glossy floor tiles and warm natural light pouring in from the floor to ceiling windows. The vacant property had been on the market for three years, the lack of interest leading the estate's trustee to periodically lower the asking price in the hopes the declining offer would tempt a buyer. When the Lynn family expressed interest in the Collins Street House in 2004, they offered $800,000 for the property, a significant bargain as many homes just like it in the area sold for over a million. Their real estate purchase contract was quickly drafted and signed, with the new homeowners handing over an $80,000 deposit, excited for their promising future in North Ride.
这处房产为渴望利用绝佳地理位置的年轻家庭提供了充足的机会。莱德北区坐落在朗科河（Langcoe River）河畔，这是一个封闭的海岸内湾，与帕拉马塔河（Parramatta River）汇合，形成了标志性的悉尼港的一支。莱德北区距离悉尼中央商务区仅15公里，备受专业人士和家庭的青睐，这里浓厚的社区氛围以及丰富的学校、公园、交通服务和购物区吸引着他们。这座庄严的柯林斯街房产吸引了林氏（Lynn）一家的目光，他们是寻找在该地区定居的台湾移民。LJ霍克房地产经纪人曾分三次带林家人参观了这栋房子。每次他们都对新刷的绿色墙壁、光亮的地板砖以及从落地窗倾泻而下的温暖自然光赞不绝口。这处空置房产已经在市场上挂牌三年了，无人问津导致该地产的受托人定期降低要价，希望不断下降的出价能吸引买家。2004年，当林家人对柯林斯街的房子表示兴趣时，他们出价80万元购买该房产，这绝对是个大便宜，因为该地区许多类似的房屋售价都超过了一百万。他们的房地产购房合同很快被起草并签署，新房主交纳了8万元的定金，对他们在莱德北区的前途充满了期待。
A sold sticker was firmly planted on the sale sign out the front of the Collins Street property, prompting local news outlets to report on the controversial purchase. Upon reading a local newspaper, the Lynn family were horrified to learn of the events that had once taken place in their new home. Having never been informed by real estate agents of the Collins Street address's shocking history, the lins felt deceived and demanded to be released from their purchase contract. LJ Hooker initially refused their request, but increasing public pressure led them to buckle. A settlement was reached wherein the Lynn family were lawfully released from the contract and refunded their full deposit. The LJ Hooker real estate agents involved in the transaction maintained they had done nothing wrong in their conduct of selling the North Ride property, but the New South Wales Office of Fair Trading started investigating the matter. In December 2004, the New South Wales Fair Trading Minister ruled that the agents had breached both the property stock and the Business Agents Act and the Fair Trading Act by not acting honestly, fairly or professionally. LJ Hooker were fined $20,900 for their misconduct, the first time such a penalty had been imposed in the state.
柯林斯街房产前方的出售告示牌上被牢牢贴上了一张“已售”贴纸，促使当地新闻媒体对这起充满争议的交易进行了报道。在阅读当地报纸时，林家人震惊地得知了他们的新家里曾经发生过的事件。由于房地产经纪人从未告知他们柯林斯街地址令人震惊的历史，林家人感到受了欺骗，并要求解除购房合同。LJ霍克起初拒绝了他们的请求，但在日益增长的公众压力下最终妥协了。双方达成了一项和解协议，林家人依法解除了合同并全额退还了定金。参与这笔交易的LJ霍克房地产经纪坚称他们在出售莱德北区房产的过程中没有做错任何事，但新南威尔士州公平交易办公室（New South Wales Office of Fair Trading）开始对该事件展开调查。2004年12月，新南威尔士州公平交易部长裁定，这些经纪人在没有诚实、公正或专业行事的情况下，违反了《财产股票和商业经纪人法》（Property Stock and Business Agents Act）以及《公平交易法》（Fair Trading Act）。LJ霍克因其不当行为被罚款20,900澳元，这是该州首次实施此类处罚。
At the time, no laws existed in New South Wales that compelled real estate agents to disclose whether a crime or death had taken place in any purchasable property. As a result of the scandal, a new state law was established requiring real estate agents to disclose the history of a property to buyers prior to its sale. The next time a for sale sign was placed out front of the Collins Street property in 2005 and carried a new detail. In small print at the bottom of the sign were the words, this is the former home of the Gonzales family. The city of Barghio The Filipino city of Barghio lies 250km north of the country's capital, Manila. It was here, in the mountain resort city nicknamed the City of Pines, where Teodoro was born in 1954, the fourth child of the close-knit Gonzales family. Fondly nicknamed Teddy, the youngest of the Gonzales siblings exhibited a strong work ethic, continuously achieving and setting new goals for himself.
当时，新南威尔士州没有任何法律强制房地产经纪人披露任何可购买的房产中是否发生过犯罪或死亡事件。作为这起丑闻的结果，制定了一项新的州法律，要求房地产经纪人在出售前向买家披露房产的历史。2005年，柯林斯街房产门前再次竖起“出售”告示牌时，带有了一个新的细节。告示牌底部的小字写着：“这是冈萨雷斯一家的前住所。”巴吉奥市（Barghio）菲律宾巴吉奥市位于该国首都马尼拉以北250公里处。正是在这里，在这个被称为“松树之城”的山区度假胜地，特奥多罗（Teodoro）于1954年出生，他是关系紧密的冈萨雷斯一族的第四个孩子。被称为“特迪”（Teddy）的冈萨雷斯家最小的孩子展现出了强烈的工作伦理，不断取得成就并为自己设定新目标。
As he grew older, Teddy showed a proclivity for academics, excelling at political science and economics. Upon acceptance into university, he studied law, having his scholarly efforts validated upon passing the bar exam. In 1977, Teddy met fellow university student, 18-year-old Mary Clara Datus, who was known to friends and family by her middle name, Loiva. The oldest of six children, Loiva was shy and soft-spoken, a delicate and poised woman. Theirs was a mutual, wistful romance, and Teddy and Loiva were married within months of their first encounter. Overt public displays of affection were frowned upon in their conservative culture, so the couple made do by constantly holding hands and affectionate habit they maintained long into their marriage. It was a respectful, devoted marriage, with the husband and wife treating each other as equals. In 1980, the couple welcomed their first child, a son they named Seth.
随着年龄的增长，特迪表现出对学术的偏好，在政治学和经济学方面表现优异。被大学录取后，他学习了法律，并在通过律师资格考试后证实了他的学术努力。1977年，特迪遇到了同校大学生、18岁的玛丽·克拉拉·达图斯（Mary Clara Datus），朋友和家人都用她的中间名洛伊娃（Loiva）称呼她。作为六个孩子中的老大，洛伊娃害羞而言语温和，是一位优雅沉着的女性。他们是一场相互的、带有怀旧色彩的浪漫恋情，特迪和洛伊娃在相遇几个月后就结婚了。他们保守的文化不赞成公开表达过度的喜爱，因此这对夫妇通过经常牵手以及他们一直保持到婚后的深情习惯来弥补。这是一场相互尊重、忠诚的婚姻，夫妻双方平等对待彼此。1980年，这对夫妇迎来了他们的第一个孩子，一个男孩，他们给他取名叫塞思（Seth）。
The origin of the unique name would remain a curious mystery, with Teddy promising to gift the story behind his son's namesake on Seth's 21st birthday. In 1983, the Gonzaleses welcomed their second child, a daughter named Claudine. Known for his idealism and determination, Teddy Gonzales worked hard to provide a good life for his family, ensuring they would never have to endure the burdens of financial struggle he faced during his own upbringing. After excelling at university, Teddy worked in real estate before moving on to property development. Assisted by Loiva, the husband and wife duo also ran a local video shop and pharmacy. In 1989, Teddy achieved his greatest work endeavor to date, building and opening an impressive four-story, 40-room hotel in the Bargo area. Boasting a restaurant and music lounge, the Queen Victoria Hotel was a roaring success and a source of great pride for the industrious Teddy.
这个独特名字的由来仍然是一个好奇的谜，特迪承诺在塞思21岁生日时送上他儿子名字背后的故事。1983年，冈萨雷斯夫妇迎来了他们的第二个孩子，一个名叫克劳丁（Claudine）的女儿。以理想主义和决心著称的特迪·冈萨雷斯努力为家人提供美好的生活，确保他们永远不必承受他自己在成长过程中所面临的财务挣扎的负担。在大学表现优异后，特迪从事房地产工作，然后转向房地产开发。在洛伊娃的协助下，这对夫妻档还经营了一家当地的录像店和药店。1989年，特迪取得了迄今为止最大的工作成就，在巴吉奥地区建造并开业了一家令人印象深刻的四层、40间客房的酒店。维多利亚女王酒店（Queen Victoria Hotel）拥有餐厅和音乐休息室，取得了巨大的成功，也是勤劳的特迪巨大的自豪源泉。
His family resided in the hotel itself, making the Queen Victoria more than just a business venture, but also their home. In 1990, the Lausanne earthquake devastated the Philippines, producing a 125-kilometer-long ground rupture that claimed to the lives of 1,600 people and leveled entire cities, including Bargo. The Queen Victoria Hotel collapsed, but not before the Gonzales family managed to flee the building, or so they thought. Upon reaching safety, a horrifying realization dawned. 9-year-old Seth had not made it out. Teddy rushed into the rubble and began crawling on his hands and knees to locate his son. To the father's relief, he found Seth alive and promptly pulled him to safety. With their hotel structurally and financially in ruin, the Gonzales family made the decision to relocate to an area where such a disaster was unlikely to happen again. Several members of their extended family had since resettled in Australia, and during visits, Loiva found Sydney particularly appealing.
他的家人就住在酒店里，这使得维多利亚女王酒店不仅仅是一项商业投资，也是他们的家。1990年，洛桑地震（Lausanne earthquake）摧毁了菲律宾，造成125公里长的地面破裂，夺去了1,600人的生命，并将包括巴吉奥在内的整个城市夷为平地。维多利亚女王酒店倒塌了，不过是在冈萨雷斯一家设法逃离大楼之前——或者他们是这么认为的。当到达安全地带时，一个可怕的现实浮现了。9岁的塞思没有逃出来。特迪冲进废墟，开始手脚并用地寻找他的儿子。令这位父亲欣慰的是，他发现塞思还活着，并迅速把他拉到安全地带。随着他们的酒店在结构和经济上陷入废墟，冈萨雷斯一家做出了决定，搬到一个不太可能再次发生这种灾难的地方。他们大家庭的几个成员此后在澳大利亚重新定居，在访问期间，洛伊娃发现悉尼特别吸引人。
It was soon decided the Australian state of New South Wales was to become the new home for the Gonzales family. Life in Australia was one of progress and success for the Gonzales family. Teddy studied to gain the relevant qualifications needed to practice law in the country, and after graduation, he opened his own law firm, T. Gonzales & Associates, where he focused on helping Filipino nationals prepare their immigration documents. Loiva worked alongside him as the office manager, taking care of the company's administrative duties. By late 1999, business was thriving. Teddy and Loiva purchased a block of land on Collins Street in the middle-class neighbourhood of North Ride, where they built their dream family home. The two Gonzales children had an ideal upbringing in Australia, with the success of their parents providing the siblings with an abundance of opportunities and financial stability.
不久之后，人们决定澳大利亚的新南威尔士州将成为冈萨雷斯一家的温馨新家。在澳大利亚的生活对冈萨雷斯一家来说是充满进步和成功的一生。特迪努力学习以获得在该国执业所需的相应资格，毕业后，他开设了自己的律师事务所——T. Gonzales & Associates，专注于帮助菲律宾国民准备移民文件。洛伊娃作为办公室经理在他身边工作，负责公司的行政事务。到1999年底，业务蒸蒸日上。特迪和洛伊娃在中产阶级社区莱德北区的柯林斯街买了一块地，在那里建造了他们梦想中的家庭住宅。冈萨雷斯家的两个孩子在澳大利亚度过了理想的成长期，父母的成功为兄妹俩提供了丰富的机会和财务稳定性。
Elders Sef was the quieter and more academically inclined, showing great promise from a young age, with many anticipating the straight-A student would one day become a doctor or lawyer. Despite his academic achievements, Sef's true passion was music. Considered quite the singer, Sef held grandiose dreams of fronting his own mainstream R&B hip-hop band. These lofty ambitions were far too unconventional for his down-to-earth career-orientated parents, so Sef began pursuing professions more worthy of their approval. Music remained a major interest of Sef's, but was relegated to a side hobby. He joined the hip-hop boy band Definite Vibes, who toured nightclubs and hosted dance parties throughout Sydney. Although their initial performances were met with mixed reviews, with criticism centred on the group's awkward stage presence, their parties were a financial success. The combined talents of Definite Vibes appeared lucrative, with Sef boasting of a $40,000 recording contract offer from a major music company.
长子塞夫（Sef）性格更安静、更倾向于学术，从小就展现出极大的前途，许多人预计这个全A学生有一天会成为一名医生或律师。尽管取得了学术成就，但塞夫真正的热情是音乐。塞夫被认为是一个相当不错的歌手，怀揣着组建自己的主流R&B嘻哈乐队的宏大梦想。这些崇高的雄心对于他脚踏实地、以事业为导向的父母来说实在是太不合常规了，于是塞夫开始追求更符合他们赞许的职业。音乐仍然是塞夫的主要兴趣，但退居为业余爱好。他加入了嘻哈男子乐队Definite Vibes，在悉尼各地的夜总会巡回演出并举办舞派对。尽管他们最初的演出褒贬不一，批评主要集中在该组合尴尬的舞台表现上，但他们的派对在财务上取得了成功。Definite Vibes的综合才华似乎很赚钱，塞夫曾吹嘘说有一家大型音乐公司向他提供了一份4万澳元的唱片合约。
The mild fame fostered Sef's dating life, and even garnered him an obsessive fan named Daisy Diaz. Daisy created and maintained a webpage titled Daisy's Dedication Page to Sefi, with an introduction that read, Hi, in case you stumbled into here by accident, I'm Daisy Diaz, and I wrote this page for my best friend, Sef. Remember that he's a sweetie and a true friend, besides being caring, trustworthy, cute, adorable, kind, understanding, intelligent, and can sing in a way that makes any girl's heart melt. And if you mess with him, you mess with me. Littered with rambling, adoring posts about Sef, Daisy's site also featured romantic song lyrics she dedicated to him, along with a candid collection of photographs of her beloved. One showed Sef with microphone in hand performing on stage with Definite Vibes, while in another, a smug Sef lay across the laps of several female models. An intimate photo of Sef posing shirtless for a professional shoot was captioned, Steam, Steam, Babyface.
小小的名气促进了塞夫的约会生活，甚至为他赢得了名叫黛西·迪亚兹（Daisy Diaz）的痴迷粉丝。黛西创建并维护了一个名为“黛西给塞菲的奉献专页”的网页，引言写道：“嗨，如果你不小心误入这里，我是黛西·迪亚兹，我为我最好的朋友塞夫写了这一页。记住，除了关怀、值得信赖、可爱、讨人喜欢、善良、理解、聪明之外，他还是一个甜心和真正的朋友，而且他的歌声能让任何女孩的心融化。如果你敢惹他，你就是惹我。”黛西的网站充斥着关于塞夫的凌乱、崇拜的帖子，还展示了她送给他的浪漫歌曲歌词，以及她深爱之人的坦率照片集。其中一张显示塞夫拿着麦克风与Definite Vibes在舞台上表演，而在另一张中，一个自鸣得意的塞夫横躺在几位女模特的大腿上。一张塞夫为专业拍摄赤膊摆姿势的亲密照片的标题是：“蒸汽，蒸汽，娃娃脸。”
In one post, Daisy wrote, Every time I close my eyes I thank the Lord that I got you babe, and you got me too. Some people think there's no such thing as a dream decent guy, while in my eyes you prove them wrong. Sefie, if you ever stopped being my friend, I would be so incomplete. Sef's friends and acquaintances also knew of his accomplishments in kickboxing, modelling, and personal training. Nevertheless, academic study remained a primary focus for Sef. After initially pursuing tertiary studies in medicine, Sef determined the field was not for him, and instead began following in his father's footsteps. He enrolled in a law degree at Macquarie University, which was much better suited to the 20 year old, as his end of semester report cards indicated he was excelling in the course. Meanwhile, Sef worked part time at his father's law firm, where he provided paralegal and IT assistants around the office.
在一篇帖子中，黛西写道：“每次我闭上眼睛，我都感谢上帝让我得到了你，宝贝，你也拥有了我。有些人认为世界上没有完美的正派男人，但在我眼里，你证明了他们是错的。塞菲，如果你有一天不再是我的朋友，我将变得如此不完整。”塞夫的朋友和熟人也知道他在自由搏击、模特和私人教练方面的成就。尽管如此，学术研究仍然是塞夫的首要任务。在最初攻读医学高等教育后，塞夫认为这个领域不适合他，转而跟随他父亲的脚步。他在麦考瑞大学（Macquarie University）攻读法律学位，这更适合这位20岁的年轻人，因为他学期末的成绩单表明他在该课程中表现优异。与此同时，塞夫在他父亲的律师事务所兼职，在办公室提供律师助理和IT协助。
Proud of their son's efforts, Teddy and Loiva rewarded him with a Green Ford Festiva, with the personalised number plate, SefG80. The vehicle became their son's pride and joy. Although academically overshadowed by her older brother, Claudine Gonzales also did well at her studies. Unlike reserved and studious Sef, her strengths arose from her outgoing and affable personality. Long drives always went by quickly when the animated and talkative Claudine was in the car. With a talent for both athletics and cooking, and hopes to one day become a teacher, the high school student had many opportunities ahead of her, but still had plenty of time to determine her path in life. The high expectations of their parents was a source of rivalry between the Gonzales siblings, and the pair were not immune to typical sibling arguments. But they were never malicious enough to break the long standing bond they shared since childhood, with Sef constantly maintaining his role as Claudine's protective older brother.
为儿子的努力感到骄傲，特迪和洛伊娃奖励了他一辆绿色福特嘉年华（Ford Festiva），个性化车牌号为SefG80。这辆车成了他们儿子的骄傲和快乐。尽管在学术上被哥哥的光芒掩盖，克劳丁·冈萨雷斯在学业上也表现得很好。与内向、好学的塞夫不同，她的优势来自于她外向、随和的个性。当生动活泼的克劳丁在车里时，长途驾驶总是过得很快。这位高中生拥有运动和烹饪方面的才华，并希望有一天能成为一名老师，她面前有许多机会，但仍有充足的时间来决定她的人生道路。父母的高希冀是冈萨雷斯兄妹之间竞争的来源，两人也未能免于典型的兄弟姐妹争吵。但他们从来没有恶毒到打破他们自童年以来分享的长期纽带，塞夫始终扮演着克劳丁保护伞般的大哥哥角色。
Sef and Claudine's lives were comfortable, albeit heavily moderated by their strict devout Catholic parents. When Claudine started a relationship with 19 year old Chris, the firm grip of her parents tightened. Strong willed and independent, Claudine pushed back, resorting to sneaking out of the family house to see her bow. Teddy and Loiva were vocal in their disapproval of the relationship, regarding Chris as a bad influence. Heated words were once exchanged between all parties, making tensions abundantly clear. Concerned that their daughter's social life was interfering with her studies, Teddy and Loiva sent Claudine to live with a relative in Melbourne, where she would finish her final year of high school without distraction. Claudine maintained contact with her Sydney based boyfriend via phone, causing her older brother to step in. Sef sent Chris veiled threats, implying he was in a criminal gang, and warning him to stay away from his sister.
塞夫和克劳丁的生活很舒适，尽管受到他们严格、虔诚的天主教父母的高度节制。当克劳丁与19岁的克里斯（Chris）开始恋爱关系时，她父母坚决的控制收紧了。意志坚强且独立的克劳丁进行了反击，诉诸于溜出家门去看她的男友。特迪和洛伊娃毫不掩饰他们对这段关系的不满，认为克里斯是个坏影响。各方曾经发生过激烈的言辞交锋，使得紧张局势显而易见。由于担心女儿的社交生活干扰学业，特迪和洛伊娃把克劳丁送到墨尔本的一个亲戚家住，在那里她可以毫无干扰地完成高中最后一年。克劳丁通过电话与她在悉尼的男友保持联系，导致她哥哥介入。塞夫向克里斯发出含蓄的威胁，暗示他是犯罪团伙成员，并警告他离他妹妹远点。
Although it was all talk, Sef's intimidating message was heard loud and clear, and Chris ended his relationship with Claudine soon after. Although stern and rigid with their children, there was little doubt Teddy and Loiva loved Sef and Claudine. The parents had plans to sell their Collins Street address in the future, using part of the payout to buy both of their children a place of their own. By July 2001, each member of the Gonzales family was working towards their own goals. Teddy was mentoring his son at his law office, anticipating Sef would one day take his place as the head of the business. Loiva was planning her upcoming wedding anniversary, where she and Teddy would renew their vows. Claudine was visiting home from Melbourne for the school holidays, excited about celebrating her upcoming 18th birthday. The morning of Tuesday, July 10, 2001, started typically for the Gonzales family.
虽然这全是空谈，但塞夫的恐吓信息被听得一清二楚，克里斯不久后便结束了与克劳丁的关系。尽管对孩子们严厉且死板，但毫无疑问，特迪和洛伊娃深爱着塞夫和克劳丁。父母计划在未来出售他们的柯林斯街房产，用部分收益为两个孩子各自买一套属于他们自己的房子。到2001年7月，冈萨雷斯一家的每个成员都在朝着自己的目标努力。特迪正在他的律师事务所指导他的儿子，预计塞夫有一天会接替他成为该业务的负责人。洛伊娃正在策划她即将到来的结婚纪念日，届时她和特迪将重誓。克劳丁为了学校假期从墨尔本回家探亲，对庆祝她即将到来的18岁生日感到兴奋。2001年7月10日星期二的早晨，对冈萨雷斯一家来说是一个平常的开始。
Teddy and Loiva rose early and left for work in separate cars. Sef headed off to Macquarie University, where he'd spend most of the morning, before commencing his part-time job at the family legal office. Later that evening, he had made plans to catch up with a friend. Claudine remained home alone with plans to spend the day studying, as she was scheduled to return to Melbourne in two days' time to resume her schooling. Later that same day, Loiva's sister, 35-year-old Emily Luna, finished work at her corporate office in Sydney's North and went to pick up her 8-year-old son from daycare. Given she was only a short drive from Loiva's place, Emily decided to pop by for a chat. It was nearing 6pm when Emily began navigating North Ride's dense suburbia towards Collins Street. When Emily pulled up to the Gonzales property, she was surprised that no one appeared to be home.
特迪和洛伊娃很早就起床，分别开车去上班。塞夫前往麦考瑞大学，他将在那里度过大部分早晨，然后开始他在家族法律事务所的兼职工作。当天晚些时候，他计划与朋友聚会。克劳丁独自留在家里，计划花一天时间学习，因为她预定在两天后返回墨尔本恢复学业。同一天晚些时候，洛伊娃的姐姐、35岁的埃米莉·卢娜（Emily Luna）在悉尼北区的公司办公室下班后，去日托中心接她8岁的儿子。鉴于她距离洛伊娃家只有很短的车程，埃米莉决定顺道去聊聊天。接近傍晚6点时，埃米莉开始穿过莱德北区密集的郊区驶向柯林斯街。当埃米莉把车停在冈萨雷斯房产前时，她惊讶地发现似乎没有人 S 在家。
The garage door was down and to the windows of the house were dark. Emily thought this strange, as her sister was typically home from work by 6. The green Ford Festiva belonging to Emily's nephew was parked in the carport, yet the Gonzales property sat in uncharacteristic, darkened silence. When something quickly swept by one of the downstairs windows, Emily presumed someone was home after all. It had been a wet winter's day and Emily was thankful the drizzling rain had stopped long enough to allow her and her son to get out of their car without needing an umbrella. They approached the entrance, noticing a faint light emanating from a frosted window alongside the front door that appeared to be coming from the kitchen at the rear of the property. Emily was certain now that someone was in the house, but after ringing the doorbell multiple times, there was no answer and nothing stirred within. Her sister owned six small dogs that always barked excitedly when someone was at the door, but the house remained eerily silent.
车库门关着，房子的窗户一片漆黑。埃米莉觉得这很奇怪，因为她姐姐通常在6点前下班回家。埃米莉侄子那辆绿色的福特嘉年华停在车棚里，然而冈萨雷斯房产却陷入了不同寻常的黑暗沉默中。当有什么东西迅速掠过一扇楼下窗户时，埃米莉以为家里终究还是有人。这是一个潮湿的冬日，埃米莉很庆幸毛毛细雨已经停了足够长的时间，让她和儿子不用带伞也能下车。他们走近入口，注意到前门旁边的磨砂玻璃窗透出微弱的光线，似乎来自房产后方的厨房。埃米莉现在确信家里有人，但在多次按门铃后，没有回应，里面也没有任何动静。她姐姐养了六只小狗，当有人在门前时总是兴奋地吠叫，但房子依然诡异地寂静。
Peering through the frosted window by the door, Emily was immediately startled by an upright figure standing on the other side, wearing a long coat and baseball cap. She thought she saw the figure move slightly, but couldn't be certain in the dim light. Alarmed, Emily remarked, I thought there was a man. Her young son had also noticed the shadowy figure, but quickly dismissed his mother's concern, explaining it was just the coat stand in the foyer with a jacket and hat hanging off it. Emily headed towards the side of the property to check a rear door. She got as far as the carport before an unsettling gut feeling compelled her not to go any further. Deciding she'd just phoned her sister later, Emily turned around, returned to her car with her son, and drove away from Collins Street. Throughout the night, Emily called the Gonzalez home phone multiple times, but was met with a busy signal on each occasion.
透过门边的磨砂窗户向内张望，埃米莉立刻被站在另一侧的一个穿着长外套和棒球帽的直立身影吓了一跳。她以为自己看到那个身影稍微动了一下，但在昏暗的光线中无法确定。埃米莉惊慌地说：“我以为有个男人。”她的小年儿子也注意到了这个黑影，但很快打消了母亲的担忧，解释说那只是门厅里的衣帽架，上面挂着夹克和帽子。埃米莉朝房产的一侧走去，想检查后门。她刚走到车棚，一种令人不安的直觉就迫使她不要再往前走了。埃米莉决定晚点再给姐姐打电话，她和儿子转过身，回到车里，开着车离开了柯林斯街。整夜，埃米莉多次拨打冈萨雷斯家的座机，但每一次都遇到忙音。
At 8.45pm that night, Seth Gonzalez and his best friend Sam dined at the Planet Hollywood restaurant on the popular main strip of George Street in Sydney. Picking hesitantly at the cheeseburger he'd ordered, Seth was reluctant to eat, telling Sam his mother had recently contracted food poisoning whilst dining out at a restaurant. During their dinner, Sam received a phone call from his younger sister Michelle, who was friends with Seth's sister, Claudine. Michelle was seeking an explanation from Seth. She'd been attempting to get in touch with Claudine all night, but her mobile phone was going unanswered, and the Gonzalez home phone line was busy. Using his mobile, Seth tried calling his family's home phone, but was met with the busy signal. He suggested someone might have been using the dial-up internet, which prevented incoming calls from connecting through. After their dinner, Sam and Seth went next door into the Galaxy World arcade, where they played video games before calling at a night at around 11pm. Seth dropped Sam home and drove the four blocks back to his family's house on Collins Street.
当晚8点45分，塞思·冈萨雷斯和他的好朋友萨姆（Sam）在悉尼繁华的主商业街乔治街（George Street）上的好莱坞星球餐厅（Planet Hollywood）用餐。塞思犹豫地挑着他点的芝士汉堡，不愿吃东西，他告诉萨姆，他的母亲最近在外面餐馆用餐时食物中毒了。在他们用餐期间，萨姆接到了他妹妹米歇尔（Michelle）的电话，米歇尔是塞思妹妹克劳丁的朋友。米歇尔在向塞思寻求解释。她整晚都在试图联系克劳丁，但她的手机无人接听，冈萨雷斯家的座机线路一直处于忙音状态。塞思用他的手机试图拨打他家的座机，但遇到了忙音。他暗示可能有人在使用拨号上网，这阻止了呼入电话的连接。晚餐后，萨姆和塞思走到隔壁的银河世界游乐场（Galaxy World arcade），玩了电子游戏，大约在晚上11点左右结束。萨姆被塞思送回家，然后塞思开车穿过四个街区回到他位于柯林斯街的家里。
At 11.48pm, a New South Wales ambulance service operator received a triple zero phone call from a young male located in the North Ride area. Frantik and shaken, the caller struggled to get the words out. His parents had been shot and were bleeding on the floor. Minutes later, Collins Street resident John Atamian was abruptly awoken by a loud thumping sound on the exterior wall of his bedroom. Someone yelled frantically, help, help, John, where are you? John recognized the distressed voice as that of his 20-year-old next door neighbor, Seth Gonzalez. Seth screamed, my parents, my family, have all been killed. Across the street, Shane Hanley was watching television when he overheard the frantic cries from outside and went to check what was going on. He was met by Seth Gonzalez sobbing hysterically.
晚上11点48分，新南威尔士州救护车服务中心接线员接到了一名位于莱德北区年轻男子的000求救电话。由于惊慌失措、浑身颤抖，打电话的人艰难地说出话来。他的父母被枪击了，正流血躺在地板上。几分钟后，柯林斯街居民约翰·阿塔米安（John Atamian）被卧室外墙上一声巨大的撞击声惊醒。有人疯狂地喊道：“救命，救命，约翰，你在哪儿？”约翰认出这个痛苦的声音是他20岁的隔壁邻居塞思·冈萨雷斯。塞思尖叫道：“我的父母，我的家人，全都被杀害了。”在街对面的肖恩·韩利（Shane Hanley）正在看电视，无意中听到外面疯狂的哭喊声，便去查看发生了什么。他遇到了歇斯底里痛哭的塞思·冈萨雷斯。
Neighbors Shane and John were able to decipher some of the young man's barely coherent blabbering, hearing something about Seth's family being shot dead. All of them gone. John raced off the phone in ambulance as Seth anxiously paced Collins Street before collapsing in an emotional heap on his family's driveway. Shane attempted to comfort the young man, but within seconds, Seth abruptly leapt up, explaining that he knew how to perform CPR and rushed into his home. Shane followed Seth into the house where 46-year-old Teddy Gonzalez was laying on a white rug by the front door. The stout, older man lay unmoving on his back in a pool of blood. Seth rushed over and wailed by his father's body, but Teddy didn't respond. The gaping wound in his chest clearly fatal. Shane attempted to pull Seth away, but the young man wrestled out of his grip and ran into another room. Following behind Seth, Shane entered the combined lounge and dining area where he saw a figure sprawled on the floor by a glass coffee table.
邻居肖恩和约翰能够辨认出这个年轻人几乎语无伦次的胡言乱语中的一些内容，听到关于塞思的家人被枪杀致死的话。“他们全都死了。”约翰连忙拨打救护车电话，而塞思则焦虑地在柯林斯街踱步，随后情绪崩溃地瘫倒在他家的车道上。肖恩试图安慰这个年轻人，但在几秒钟内，塞思突然跳了起来，解释说他知道如何做心肺复苏，并冲进了他的家里。肖恩跟着塞思走进屋里，46岁的特迪·冈萨雷斯正躺在前门的一张白色地毯上。这个身材粗壮的中年人仰面躺在一滩血泊中，一动不动。塞思冲过去在父亲的尸体旁痛哭，但特迪没有回应。他胸前巨大的伤口显然是致命的。肖恩试图把塞思拉开，但这个年轻人挣脱了他的控制，跑进了另一个房间。紧随塞思身后，肖恩进入了起居和用餐合并区，在那里他看到一个身影瘫倒在玻璃茶几旁边的地板上。
It was the petite body of 43-year-old Loiva Gonzalez. She, too, was unresponsive. Her body riddled with open, bloody wounds. Seth rushed back and forth between his parents, weeping hysterically. Fearful the perpetrators may still be in the house. Shane coked Seth outside, before rushing back to his own house and calling 000. Shane waited on the line until he heard the sound of police sirens approaching. Police and paramedics swiftly descended on Collins Street. Though a immediate entry into the Gonzalez home was halted due to fears the perpetrators may still be inside. Eventually, armed officers escorted a medic into the dimly-lit interior, entering via the garage. They found the bodies of Teddy and Loiva on the ground floor of the address before cautiously heading upstairs, where another grim discovery was made.
那是43岁的洛伊娃·冈萨雷斯娇小的身躯。她同样没有反应。她的身体布满了张开的、血淋淋的伤口。塞思在父母之间跑来跑去，歇斯底里地哭泣。担心行凶者可能还在屋里，肖恩把塞思带到外面，然后赶回自己的家拨打000。肖恩在电话线上等待，直到听到警车鸣笛声越来越近。警察和医护人员迅速涌向柯林斯街。尽管由于担心行凶者可能仍在里面而阻止了对冈萨雷斯家的立即进入。最终，武装警官护送一名医务人员进入光线昏暗的内部，通过车库进入。他们在该地址的底层发现了特迪和洛伊娃的尸体，然后小心翼翼地走向楼上，在那里有了另一个可怕的发现。
The bloodied body of 18-year-old Claudine Gonzalez was found curled in the fetal position inside her bedroom. A red jumper placed over her to cover the savage injuries she had sustained. None of the victims had been shot as initially suspected, but all had been brutally stabbed. In total, Teddy Gonzalez had suffered 12 injuries, a majority of them centralized in his upper body. His lungs and heart had been penetrated, whilst his jugular vein, carotid artery and spine were severed. The spinal injury alone would have partially paralyzed the Teddy. Defensive wounds on his arms and fingers indicated he attempted to fight for his life. Loiva Gonzalez sustained wounds to her face, back, chest, abdomen and groin, along with defensive wounds to her hands and arms.
18岁克劳丁·冈萨雷斯的血泊尸体被发现蜷缩在她的卧室里。一件红色的套头衫盖在她身上，以掩盖她所受到的残忍伤害。受害者中没有一人像最初怀疑的那样被枪杀，但所有人都被残酷地刺伤。总共，特迪·冈萨雷斯遭受了12处伤害，其中大部分集中在上半身。他的肺部和心脏被刺穿，而他的颈静脉、颈动脉和脊椎被切断。仅脊椎损伤就会使特迪部分瘫痪。他手臂和手指上的防御性伤口表明他曾试图为生命而战。洛伊娃·冈萨雷斯的脸部、背部、胸部、腹部和腹股沟都受到了伤，手和手臂上也有防御性伤口。
Her six-centimetre-long laceration across her throat had severed her windpipe, but the lack of active bleeding indicated this deep cut had been injured. Upstairs, Claudine Gonzalez had been bludgeoned with a heavy object, fracturing her skull. Distinctive arc-shaped dents in the wall above her body identified the weapon as likely to have been a baseball bat. Claudine had also been strangled and stabbed, with seven wounds located throughout her body, five to her neck and two to her torso. Established evidence, coupled with the body temperatures of the victims, were used to determine the order and approximate time in which each member of the Gonzalez family was murdered. Claudine Gonzalez was targeted first, with unanswered text messages to a friend leading investigators to presume she was confronted shortly after 4pm. Open school textbooks on the Year 12 students desk indicated she was ambushed while studying and did not anticipate the attack. At 4.50pm, Lover Gonzalez left work with a colleague whom she dropped off at their house before heading to Collins Street.
她长达六厘米的喉部撕裂伤切断了气管，但缺乏活动性出血表明这条深切口是在死后造成的。楼上，克劳丁·冈萨雷斯被重物击打，头骨碎裂。她尸体上方墙壁上独特的弧形凹痕表明凶器很可能是棒球棒。克劳丁还被勒死和刺伤，全身共有七处伤口，五处在颈部，两处在躯干。确凿的证据加上受害者的体温，被用来确定冈萨雷斯家庭每个成员被谋杀的顺序和大约时间。克劳丁·冈萨雷斯是第一个被针对的目标，未回复朋友的短信导致调查人员推测她在下午4点刚过不久就遭到对峙。12年级学生桌上打开的学校教科书表明她在学习时遭到伏击，并没有预料到这次袭击。下午4点50分，洛伊娃与一位同事一起下班，她在同事家放下对方后前往柯林斯街。
Arriving home soon after, Lover was confronted by her killer upon entering the living space. Mobile phone records of Teddy Gonzalez showed he left work around 6.20pm, placing two calls home during his drive, both going unanswered. He was immediately struck by his killer upon entering the front door. As the last surviving member of his family, Seth Gonzalez sat hunched on the ground inside the garage of his family home in a heightened emotional state, requesting rosary beads. He stumbled through his recollections of the night to police, explaining that he discovered the bodies of his family members upon returning home from an evening out with a friend. He spotted one or two perpetrators fleeing southward down Collins Street, and after a futile attempt to give chase, Seth rushed back home and performed CPR on his parents before calling emergency services and seeking help from his neighbors. Seth couldn't identify anyone specific who would target his family, but recalled an incident from the night before that police believed may have been connected. The Gonzalez family were driving home together from Claudine's 18th birthday dinner when a road rage incident occurred with another vehicle.
不久后回到家，洛伊娃一进入起居空间就遇到了凶手。特迪·冈萨雷斯的手机记录显示他在下午6点20分左右离开公司，在开车回家期间打了两个电话回家，但都无人接听。他一进前门就被凶手袭击了。作为家里唯一幸存的成员，塞思·冈萨雷斯情绪激动地驼着背坐在自家车库的地板里，要求要念珠。他向警方磕磕绊绊地回忆当晚的经过，解释说他在与朋友外出聚会回家后发现了家庭成员的尸体。他看到一两名行凶者向南逃跑，沿着柯林斯街逃窜，在徒劳地试图追赶后，塞思急忙跑回家并对父母进行心肺复苏，然后拨打紧急服务电话并向邻居寻求帮助。塞思无法认出任何特定会针对他家的人，但他回想起前一天晚上发生的一起事件，警方认为这可能有关联。冈萨雷斯一家在参加完克劳丁18岁生日晚宴后一起开车回家时，与另一辆车发生了路怒事件。
The driver of the other vehicle sped past the Gonzalez's car yelling out, quote, bloody Asians. The possibility the Gonzalez slayings were a racially motivated hate crime was further substantiated by evidence found at the crime scene. A wall hanging in an area by the Gonzalez's kitchen had been torn down and replaced with graffiti scrawled in blue spray paint that read, quote, fuck off Asians, with the letters KKK sprayed nearby. There were also indications that a robbery had taken place, as Teddy's briefcase and Deloiva's handbag had been clearly rummaged through, leaving their contents scattered in disarray. The doors of several wardrobes were left hanging wide open, suggesting someone had hastily looked inside them. The cord to the landline phone had been cut, explaining why the many calls made to the homestead throughout the evening had been met with a busy signal. Loewe's pet dogs were all found unharmed, though restrained or behind closed doors. If a robbery had taken place, it appeared to have been an incompetent one.
另一辆车的司机超速驶过冈萨雷斯的汽车，大喊大叫，引述：“血腥的亚洲人。”冈萨雷斯谋杀案是一起出于种族动机的仇恨犯罪的可能性，得到了犯罪现场发现的证据的进一步证实。冈萨雷斯家厨房附近区域的一幅挂毯被扯下，取而代之的是用蓝色喷漆乱涂乱画的涂鸦，上面写着，引述：“滚开，亚洲人”，附近还喷有“KKK”字样。还有迹象表明发生了一起抢劫，因为特迪的公文包和洛伊娃的手提包显然被翻找过，里面的东西杂乱无章地散落着。几个衣柜的门大开着，暗示有人匆忙地往里面看。座机电话线被切断了，这解释了为什么整个晚上打到家里的许多电话都遇到了忙音。洛伊娃的宠物狗被发现时都毫发无损，只是被拴着或关在门后。如果发生了一起抢劫，那似乎是一起无能的抢劫。
The Gonzalez's house was neat and orderly, without the overt signs of mess and carelessness akin to typical robberies. Nothing appeared to be obviously ransacked or missing. Expensive jewellery and electronics had been ignored, as was the $700 cash in Teddy's wallet and the $300 in Loewe's handbag. The wardrobes were open, but their contents were undisturbed. Notably, the blood spatter on the floor underneath Teddy's briefcase and Deloiva's handbag showed the items did not fall to the ground haphazardly mid-attack, but were later emptied and planted there. This was the first clear indication to investigators that the crime scene was not an amateur robbery, but was instead carefully staged to appear like one. Other evidence correlated with this theory. The flywire mesh screening that had once covered the window above the kitchen sink was found discarded outside, having been slashed and ripped off its frame.
冈萨雷斯的房子整洁有序，没有典型抢劫那种明显的混乱和粗心大意。没有任何东西被明显翻找或失窃。昂贵的珠宝和电子产品被忽视了，特迪钱包里的700元现金和洛伊娃手提包里的300元也是如此。衣柜敞开着，但里面的东西没有被打扰。值得注意的是，特迪的公文包和洛伊娃手提包下方的地板上的血迹表明，这些物品在袭击中并非杂乱无章地掉落到地上，而是后来被掏空并摆放在那里的。这是给调查人员的第一个明确迹象，表明犯罪现场不是业余抢劫，而是经过精心策划以使其看起来像。其他证据也印证了这一理论。曾经覆盖厨房水槽上方窗户的飞虫网纱布在外面被发现，它被割破并从框架上撕了下来。
Upon first glance, it appeared this window had been the entry point for the perpetrator. However, there were no pry marks on the window frame or latch, implying the frame was not removed with any overt force or sense of urgency. Furthermore, there were no shoe prints found on the kitchen counter inside, which would be expected if the perpetrator climbed in through the window. The estimated timings of each victim's murder was also of great interest to investigators, as it showed the killer had remained inside the Gonzales House for several hours, between 4pm and 7pm. This didn't correspond with expectations of a brash and sudden home invasion, but implied the killer patiently lay in wait as each family member returned home, attacking them one by one with calculated purpose. Adding to the evidence the killer acted methodically was the discovery of fresh water found pulled on the tiles of a bathroom, revealing someone had only recently taken a shower there. This act couldn't have been performed by the victims, as it was determined the shower was taken after their deaths. It was likely the killer had taken the time to rinse off after carrying out the murders, instead of hastily fleeing the scene.
乍一看，这扇窗户似乎是行凶者的入口。然而，窗框或插销上没有任何撬痕，这意味着框架的拆除没有任何明显的武力或紧迫感。此外，内部的厨房台面上没有发现鞋印，如果行凶者爬窗而入，这是可以预料的。每位受害者谋杀的估计时间也引起了调查人员的极大兴趣，因为它表明凶手在下午4点到7点之间在冈萨雷斯家里呆了几个小时。这与鲁莽、突然的住宅入侵的预期不符，而是暗示凶手在每个家庭成员回家时耐心潜伏，以精打细算的目的一个接一个地攻击他们。增加凶手有条不紊行事证据的是在一间浴室的地砖上发现的积水，这表明最近有人在那里洗过澡。这个行为不可能是受害者做的，因为经确定淋浴是在他们死后进行的。凶手很可能在实施谋杀后花时间冲洗干净，而不是仓皇逃离现场。
Aside from the baseball bat, the only other weapon used in the crime appeared to have been a knife. A knife block displayed on the kitchen bench had two of its largest and longest knives missing. Forensic experts determined the smaller of the missing knives could have caused the type of wounds inflicted on teddy, loyver and clodine. The murder weapons having been sourced from inside the Gonzales Home stood out as strange and introduced some major red flags in the racially motivated home invasion theory. A home invasion, especially one committed against a specific target, involved a certain level of planning and preparation. Perpetrators would not run the risk of arriving to the scene unarmed. Bloody shoe prints tracked throughout the house did not match the footwear worn by anyone who had since entered the crime scene, including victims, police officers, neighbours and sef Gonzales. Investigators were quick to identify the style of shoe, a laceless UK size 7 human brand running shoe, believed to have been worn by the killer.
除了棒球棒，犯罪中使用的唯一其他武器似乎是一把刀。厨房台面上展示的一个刀座不见了其中两把最大、最长的刀。法医专家确定，较小的一把失踪刀具可能造成了对特迪、洛伊娃和克劳丁造成的伤口类型。凶器源自冈萨雷斯家中，这显得很奇怪，并在出于种族动机的住宅入侵理论中引入了一些主要的危险信号。住宅入侵，特别是针对特定目标的入侵，涉及一定水平的规划和准备。行凶者不会冒着手无寸铁到达现场的风险。在全屋追踪到的血腥鞋印与此后来到犯罪现场的任何人（包括受害者、警察、邻居和塞思·冈萨雷斯）穿的鞋类都不匹配。调查人员迅速确定了鞋子的款式，即一双无鞋带的英国7码Human牌跑步鞋，据信是凶手穿的。
Police doorknocked the local area and spoke with neighbours, but no one reported hearing any suspicious noises or signs of an altercation. Potential witness accounts were impeded by the wild winter weather that evening, moderate to heavy rain, rolling thunder and gusts of wind. Police dogs were brought to the scene, but they were unable to pick up a cent. At 3am on July 11, the sole surviving member of the Gonzales family was escorted to a local police station to provide an official written statement. Sef detailed his morning trip into university and his afternoon spent working at his father's law office. It was approaching 5pm when Sef left work to meet up with his friend Sam for their planned catch up. He then received a text message from Sam asking to postpone their meeting until later that evening as he had committed to playing a game of basketball. Sef agreed and decided to go home in the meantime.
警察在当地挨家挨户敲门并与邻居交谈，但没有人报告听到任何可疑的声音或争吵的迹象。当晚狂野的冬日天气阻碍了潜在的目击证词，中雨到大雨、阵阵雷声和强风。警犬被带到了现场，但它们一无所获。7月11日凌晨3点，冈萨雷斯一家唯一的幸存者被护送到当地警察局，以提供一份官方的书面供词。塞夫详细描述了他早上去大学以及下午在父亲律所工作的经历。接近下午5点时，塞夫下班去见他的朋友萨姆，进行他们计划好的聚会。随后他收到萨姆发来的一条短信，要求将聚会推迟到当天晚些时候，因为他答应去打一场篮球。塞夫同意了，并决定在此期间先回家。
During the drive to North Ride, Sef called both his mother's mobile phone and the family house phone, but neither calls were answered. Sef arrived home at around 6pm, with the unanswered calls and overall darkened stillness of the house, leading him to presume no one was home. As he remained sitting in his vehicle waiting for a break in the rainy weather, he received a phone call from Sam. The pair agreed to meet up at 8pm. As a means to fill the two hours before he met with Sam, Sef drove off towards Kingsgrove, a suburb 22km south of North Ride. A friend of his had recently moved there, so Sef thought it would be a good time to visit and check out his new place. Upon arriving to Kingsgrove, Sef didn't have the address, so he drove around aimlessly attempting to find his friend's new house. Realising it was nearing the time he was due to meet up with Sam, Sef gave up on seeing the Kingsgrove house and went to pick up Sam instead.
在驱车前往北赖德的途中，塞夫分别拨打了母亲的手机和家里的固定电话，但都没有人接听。塞夫在大约晚上6点到家，未接通的电话和整个房子昏暗的寂静让他推测家里没有人。当他坐在车里等待雨停时，他接到了萨姆的电话。两人同意晚上8点见面。为了打发与萨姆见面前的两个小时，塞夫开车前往金斯格罗夫，这是一个位于北赖德以南22公里的郊区。他的一个朋友最近刚搬到那里，所以塞夫觉得这是参观并看看他新家的好时机。到达金斯格罗夫后，塞夫没有地址，于是他漫无目的地开车兜风，试图找到朋友的新房子。意识到快到与萨姆见面的时候了，塞夫放弃了寻找金斯格罗夫房子的想法，转而去接萨姆。
The pair left Sam's house at around 8.15pm and drove into the city where they dined at Planet Hollywood, then played in the Galaxy World Arcade, leaving shortly after 11pm. CCTV footage retrieved from cameras along George Street confirmed Sef's whereabouts at this time. Sef dropped Sam home and drove onwards towards his house, where he parked his car in the carport. Upon entering the house via a side-access door, he immediately came across his father's body in the foyer, misidentifying the stab wounds in Teddy's chest for bullet holes. Sef called 000 and requested an ambulance before discovering the bodies of his mother and sister. Whilst tending to his sister's wounds, Sef overheard a sound from downstairs, followed by the side gate slamming shut outside. He raced into the garage and pressed the button that opened the roller door.
两人于晚上8点15分左右离开萨姆的家，驱车进入市区，在好莱坞星球餐厅用餐，随后在银河世界游乐场玩耍，并在晚上11点后不久离开。乔治街沿线摄像机调取闭路电视画面证实了塞夫当时行踪。塞夫将萨姆送回家，然后继续开车驶向自己的家，将车停在车棚里。通过侧面通道门进入房屋后，他立刻在门厅发现了父亲的尸体，误将泰迪胸前的刺刀伤当成了弹孔。塞夫拨打000并请求派遣救护车，随后发现了母亲和妹妹的遗体。在照料妹妹的伤口时，塞夫听到楼下传来一个声音，随后外面传来了侧门猛烈关上的声音。他冲进车库，按下了开启卷帘门的按钮。
It slowly creaked upwards and when there was enough space, Sef squeezed through the gap underneath and ran out onto the road. He caught sight of a male figure running away towards a nearby intersection. He thought he glimpsed another man fleeing too, but couldn't be certain that it wasn't just the shadow of the first person. As news of the triple homicide spread, speculation ran rife over who could be responsible for the horrific crime. Rumors circulated about the legitimacy of Teddy's legal business, suggesting the father may have been involved in some shady dealings. There were unconfirmed claims that Sef had ties with a local criminal gang and the killings could be a warning for the 20-year-old. The hate crime theory was heavily hypothesized, with images of the racist graffiti inside the home featured throughout news reports. Suspicions arose that there was more than meets the eye for the seemingly typical upper middle-class family, as members of the public considered whether the slayings were revenge for a personal vendetta.
卷帘门缓缓向上发出吱嘎声，当有足够空间时，塞夫从下方的缝隙挤过去，跑到了路上。他瞥见一个男人的身影正朝附近的一个十字路口逃跑。他以为自己也瞥见了另一个逃跑的男子，但无法确定那是否只是第一个人的影子。随着三起谋杀案的消息传开，关于谁可能是这起可怕罪行的幕后黑手的猜测满天飞。关于泰迪合法业务合法的谣言四处流传，暗示这位父亲可能卷入了某些见不得光的交易。有未经证实的声称称塞夫与当地一个犯罪帮派有联系，这些杀戮可能是对这名20岁男子的警告。仇恨犯罪的理论受到了广泛的猜测，房屋内部种族主义涂鸦的照片在整个新闻报道中都有出现。人们开始怀疑这个看似典型的中产阶级家庭背后隐藏着更多内幕，公众开始思考这些谋杀是否是对个人宿怨的报复。
A look into Teddy Gonzalez's background revealed that during the late 1990s, he had come under the radar of the Department of Immigration for allegedly helping Filipino immigrants lie on documents seeking refugee status in Australia. Teddy's actions were noticed by government officials, and he was subsequently charged with four counts of falsifying documentation. Two of these charges were dropped, and the remaining went to trial, where Teddy was eventually cleared. Nevertheless, Teddy had ruffled the feathers of several clients who accused the immigration lawyer of keeping the money they paid him, despite their visa applications being denied. Earlier in 2001, Teddy was overheard in his office arguing on the phone in his native Filipino language of Tagalog. In an uncharacteristic display of anger, the usually proud and resolute Teddy shouted, fuck you, before slamming down the phone. When a work colleague asked what was wrong, Teddy explained that he was in the process of selling a property to an investor in the Philippines. Dealings had become heated, with the investor threatening to kill his family.
对泰迪·冈萨雷斯背景的调查显示，在20世纪90年代末，他曾引起移民局的注意，因为他涉嫌帮助菲律宾移民在寻求澳大利亚难民身份的文件上撒谎。泰迪的行为引起了政府官员的注意，随后他被控四项伪造文件的罪名。其中两项指控被撤销，其余的进入审判程序，泰迪最终被无罪释放。尽管如此，泰迪还是惹恼了几位客户，他们指控这位移民律师私吞了他们支付的钱，尽管他们的签证申请被拒绝了。2001年早些时候，有人无意中听到泰迪在办公室里用他的母语他加禄语在电话里争吵。在一次罕见的愤怒表现中，这个通常骄傲而坚决的泰迪大喊“去你的”，然后重重地挂断了电话。当一位同事问怎么了时，泰迪解释说他正在将菲律宾的一处房产卖给一位投资者。交易变得十分激烈，投资者威胁要杀死他的全家。
Teddy didn't appear overly rattled by the threat, but soon afterwards he placed a phone call to his father where he cryptically remarked, I have a big family problem I'm dealing with, but I think I can solve it. On July 13, three days after the murders of his father, mother and sister, Seth Gonzalez fronted the media, offering a $100,000 reward for information that would help identify his family's killer. Expressing his overwhelming grief, Seth told reporters, quote, It is difficult to explain the love and ties in my family, but if you were to picture the four corners of the world, in my world, we were the four. The three corners of my world are now gone. My family, friends and myself would like to ask anyone out there to please help us. Later that same day, Seth Gonzalez visited his father's accountant and inquired about accessing his inheritance. Taking into account the Gonzalez's north-right property and its contents, including two vehicles, jewellery, savings, as well as Teddy's commercial properties, the entire Gonzalez estate was valued at $1.5 million.
泰迪对这个威胁并没有表现得过于惊慌，但不久之后他给父亲打了个电话，并在电话中隐晦地评论道：“我正在处理一个很大的家庭问题，但我认为我能解决它。”7月13日，在他的父亲、母亲和妹妹被谋杀三天后，塞思·冈萨雷斯公开面对媒体，悬赏10万澳元征集有助于确认其家人凶手身份的信息。塞思表达了自己压抑的悲伤，对记者说：“很难解释我家庭中的爱和纽带，但如果你把世界的四个角落想象成我的世界，在我的世界里，我们就是这四个人。我世界的三个角落现在已经消失了。我的家人、朋友和我都想请求外面的人请帮帮我们。”就在同一天晚些时候，塞思·冈萨雷斯拜访了他父亲的会计，并询问了继承遗产的事宜。考虑到冈萨雷斯的北赖德房产及其内含物品，包括两辆汽车、珠宝、存款以及泰迪的商业房产，冈萨雷斯的整个遗产估值为150万澳元。
In addition, Teddy had multiple investment properties in the Philippines, with an estimated value of around $1.3 million. With his parents and sister now deceased, 20-year-old Seth Gonzalez had just become the sole beneficiary of his family's entire multi-million dollar fortune. A joint funeral service was held for Teddy, Lover and Claudine Gonzalez on July 20, 2001 at North Ride's Holy Spirit Catholic Church. Close to 300 mourners gathered to pay their respects to the slain family, including the colleagues and clients of the Gonzalez legal office and Claudine's many school friends. Also present were members of law enforcement, still in the midst of conducting their investigations into finding the family's killer. Eulogies fondly remembered the lives of the father, mother and daughter, whilst grieving friends and family retold their final encounters with the deceased. Never expecting these fleeting moments would become the last time they would see the trio. Seated on the front pew was Seth Gonzalez, surrounded by supporters.
此外，泰迪在菲律宾有多处投资性房产，估计价值约130万澳元。随着父母和妹妹的离世，20岁塞思·冈萨雷斯刚刚成为家族数百万美元全部财产的唯一受益人。2001年7月20日，泰迪、洛伊弗和克劳丁·冈萨雷斯的联合葬礼在北赖德圣灵天主教堂举行。近300名哀悼者聚集在一起，向被杀害的一家人致敬，其中包括冈萨雷斯律所的同事和客户以及克劳丁的许多校友。现场还有执法人员，他们仍在继续进行寻找凶手的调查。悼词深情追忆了父亲、母亲和女儿的一生，悲伤的朋友和家人则讲述了他们与死者的最后相遇。绝没有想到这些短暂的时刻会成为他们最后一次见到这三人。坐在前排长椅上的是塞思·冈萨雷斯，周围环绕着支持者。
The young man kept his head bowed throughout most of the service, until he was summoned before the crowd to deliver his eulogy. Seth lamented his father as his hero, referencing his childhood terror of being trapped after the Lausanne earthquake, before Teddy bravely rescued him. He expressed sadness at now never knowing the backstory of his unique name. A story Teddy had promised to reveal on Seth's 21st birthday. Seth said, I will never find out the meaning of my name because it was taken away along with my father. That part of me will always be incomplete. At the conclusion of Seth's eulogy, he took a deep breath, and in an act that would be later described by witnesses as bizarre and uncomfortable, he began singing a solo acapella rendition of the R&B ballad One Sweet Day by Mariah Carey and Boys to Men. It was a flawless performance given without a single tear, regarded by listeners as emotionally detached, self-indulgent, and inappropriate given the somber circumstances of the gathering.
这个年轻人几乎在整个仪式中都低着头，直到他被召集到人群前发表悼词。塞思将父亲哀悼为他的英雄，他回忆起自己童年时在洛桑地震后被困的恐惧，当时泰迪勇敢地救了他。他为现在永远无法得知自己独特名字的背景而感到悲伤。泰迪曾承诺在塞思21岁生日时揭晓这个故事。塞思说：“我永远不会知道我名字的含义，因为它随着我的父亲一起被剥夺了。我生命中的那部分将永远不完整。”在塞思的悼词结束时，他深吸了一口气，做出了一个后来被目击者描述为诡异且令人不适的举动——他开始独唱玛丽亚·凯莉和大人小孩双人组的R&B抒情歌曲《甜蜜的一天》（One Sweet Day）。这是一场完美无瑕的表演，没有流下一滴眼泪，在听众看来，鉴于聚会阴郁的环境，这种表现显得情感抽离、自我放纵且不合时宜。
Teddy, Loiva and Claudine were buried together on the grounds of Macquarie Park Cemetery. Their memorial plaques declaring their cherished trio would forever live in the hearts and smiles of those they left behind, including Seth. It hadn't just been funeral attendees who had noticed Seth Gonzalez's odd behaviour in the days following the murder of his family. Police were suspicious of Seth from the moment he made the frantic call to triple zero on the late night of July 10, 2001. Sorry? What? Someone's what? What trouble are you in?
泰迪、洛伊弗和克劳丁被合葬在麦考瑞公园公墓的土地上。他们的纪念牌匾上刻着，他们深爱的三人组将永远活在包括塞思在内的那些他们留下的人的心中和微笑里。不仅仅是葬礼出席者注意到了塞思·冈萨雷斯在家人被谋杀后的几天里的古怪行为。从2001年7月10日深夜塞思拨打紧急求救电话的那一刻起，警方就对塞思产生了怀疑。抱歉？什么？谁的什么？你遇到了什么麻烦？
What trouble are you in? North ride. And your parents are by saying shot, have they? No. Yeah, we will. We will send in ambulance now. Minutes after midnight on July 11, 2001, first responders raced to Collins Street following alarming reports that a gunman was active in the area. They arrived to the scene, a nondescript homestead belonging to the Filipino-Australian Gonzalez family, where they found a 20-year-old Seth Gonzalez sitting on the floor of the open garage. The young man was in hysterics, imploring paramedics and police officers to enter his house and help his family.
你遇到了什么麻烦？北赖德。你的父母说他们被枪击了吗？没有。是的，我们会。我们现在就派救护车去。2001年7月11日午夜过后几分钟，急救人员冲向柯林斯街，此前有惊人的报告称该地区有枪手活动。他们到达了现场，这是一处属于菲澳裔冈萨雷斯一家的普通住宅，他们在敞开的车库地板上找到了20岁的塞思·冈萨雷斯。这个年轻人歇斯底里，恳求医护人员和警察进入他的家并帮助他的家人。
Attending police were quick to notice Seth Gonzalez's odd behaviour at the scene. Although sobbing intensely, Seth's face remained completely dry, not a single tear was shed. He appeared frenzied and panicked, yet his answers to questions were noticeably thought out and rational. He claimed to have performed CPR on both of his parents and later added he had tended to the wounds of his sister with his bare hands. There was bloodstaining on the leg of his jeans, a little on the back sleeve of his jumper, as well as a few spots on his boots. Barely anything given the state of the victims. Seth was quick to offer a dubious explanation, claiming that the rain, at which point was only a drizzle, had washed most of the bloodstaining from his clothing and he had wiped the remainder from his hands onto the damp lawn. An astute police officer noticed some blue coloured staining on the left sleeve of Seth's jumper towards the edge of the cuff.
出警的警察很快注意到塞思·冈萨雷斯在现场的古怪行为。尽管痛苦地啜泣，但塞思的脸完全是干的，没有流下一滴眼泪。他显得狂乱和惊慌，但对问题的回答却明显经过深思熟虑且合乎理性。他声称对他的父母都实施了心肺复苏术，后来又补充说他曾用双手处理了妹妹的伤口。他的牛仔裤腿上有血迹，套头衫的后袖上有一点，靴子上也有几个点。考虑到受害者的状况，这几乎不算什么。塞思很快给出了一个可疑的解释，声称当时只是细雨，雨水已经冲刷掉了他衣服上的大部分血迹，他把剩下的血迹从手上擦到了潮湿的草坪上。一名精明的警察注意到塞思套头衫的左袖口边缘有一些蓝色的污渍。
The colour resembled the spray paint used to graffiti racial obscenities on an interior wall in the Gonzalez house. Later analysis determined this staining on Seth's jumper was indeed a blue paint. A shoebox was found in a wardrobe in Seth's bedroom and according to the label had had originally contained a pair of UK size 7 human brand running shoes. The shoes themselves were missing from Seth's footwear collection, but were an exact match to the bloody footprints tracked through the crime scene by the killer. Seth insisted the shoes had never belonged to him, they had been purchased by his father for a cousin who lived in the Philippines. Knowing a thorough search of his bedroom was underway, Seth confided to a police officer about a pornographic video he had hidden away in a dresser drawer and he appeared very embarrassed by the prospect of investigators finding it. Given the tragic circumstances, the officer felt uncomfortable that Seth's primary concern was about his pornography stash and not the murder of his family. Nearly a week after the murders, Seth Gonzalez was escorted by police to Collins Street after agreeing to participate in a full reenactment of the night of July 10.
这种颜色类似于冈萨雷斯家内墙上喷涂种族主义粗言秽语的喷漆。后来的分析确定，塞思套头衫上的这种污渍确实是蓝色油漆。在塞思卧室的衣柜里发现了一个鞋盒，根据标签，它原本装着一双英国7码的人类品牌跑步鞋。鞋子本身从塞思的鞋柜里不见了，但与凶手在犯罪现场留下的血脚印完全吻合。塞思坚信这双鞋从来不属于他，它们是他父亲为住在菲律宾的一个表亲买的。得知对他的卧室的彻底搜查正在进行中，塞思向一名警察吐露了他藏在梳妆台抽屉里的色情录影带，并且对调查人员发现它的可能性显得非常尴尬。鉴于悲惨的环境，这名警官感到不安的是，塞思最关心的居然是他藏匿的色情制品，而不是他家人的谋杀案。谋杀案发生近一周后，塞思·冈萨雷斯在同意参与7月10日晚上的完整情景重现后，被警方护送到柯林斯街。
Calmly and precisely, Seth retraced and described his movements upon finding the brutalized bodies of his parents and sister. At no time did he indicate reliving these traumatic events was causing him any distress. Of particular interest to investigators was the claims Seth had witnessed the perpetrator fleeing the house and had subsequently given chase. Police tested this theory and determined by the time Seth would have exited the house via the garage and emerged under Collins Street, the killer would have most certainly been long gone and completely out of sight. CCTV footage retrieved from cameras within Sydney's CBD confirmed Seth's alibi on the night of July 10, proving he had dined out and played arcade games with a friend between the hours of 8pm and 11pm. Seth's claims that he was out driving around Kings Grove prior to this meetup could not be verified, nor could his whereabouts between the crucial time frame in which the murders were carried out, sometime between 4pm and 7pm. A client of Teddy Gonzalez's law firm Tile Police, they had stopped by the Collins Street home between 4.10pm and 4.30pm on July 10, around the approximate time Claudine was killed. As this witness dropped some documents into the Gonzalez's letterbox, they recalled seeing a green Ford Festiva parked out the front of the house.
塞思冷静而精确地回溯并描述了他发现父母和妹妹遭受残酷虐待的尸体时的举动。他没有表现出任何因重温这些创伤性事件而感到痛苦的迹象。调查人员特别感兴趣的是，塞思声称自己目睹了凶手逃离房屋并随后进行了追捕。警方对这一理论进行了测试，并确定当塞思通过车库离开房屋并出现在柯林斯街时，凶手肯定已经走得很远，完全消失在视线之外了。悉尼中央商务区内摄像头调取的闭路电视画面证实了塞思在7月10日晚上的不在场证明，证明他在晚上8点到11点之间与朋友一起外出用餐并玩了街机游戏。塞思声称在此次聚会之前他开车在金斯格罗夫附近兜风的说法无法得到证实，他在实施谋杀的关键时间段（即下午4点到晚上7点之间）的行踪也无法证实。泰迪·冈萨雷斯律师事务所的一位客户向警方反映，他们在7月10日下午4点10分到4点30分之间曾在柯林斯街的家中停留，大约是在克劳丁被杀害的时间前后。当这名目击者将一些文件投入冈萨雷斯的信箱时，他们回忆说看到一辆绿色的福特福斯蒂瓦停在房子前面。
This was not the only witness who saw Seth Gonzalez's vehicle parked at the Collins Street address within the time frame of the murders. Emily Luna, Seth's aunt, had visited the Gonzalez home at approximately 6pm on July 10 and recalled Seth's Ford Festiva was parked in the carport. She believed someone was home at the time as she had spotted movement through a window and noted the kitchen light was on, yet when Emily rang the doorbell several times, there was no answer. Emily's statement wasn't surprising given that Seth's written statement also declared he had stopped by the house around this time. Seth said it had been raining so he remained in the car and had never entered the house before deciding to drive off to Kingsgrove to visit his friend. Yet, Emily Luna provided two crucial details during her interviews that contradicted Seth's statement. Firstly, Emily distinctly remembered it was not raining when she visited the house as she didn't require the use of her umbrella. During further talks with police, Emily also admitted that she did not see Seth sitting in his vehicle at the time.
这不是唯一一个在谋杀案发生时间段内看到塞思·冈萨雷斯的车停在柯林斯街地址的目击者。塞思的姑姑艾米丽·卢娜在7月10日晚上6点左右拜访了冈萨雷斯家，并回忆说塞思的福特福斯蒂瓦停在车棚里。她相信当时家里有人，因为她透过窗户看到有动静，并注意到厨房的灯亮着，然而当艾米丽按了几次门铃时，却无人应答。艾米丽的证词并不令人意外，因为塞思的书面供词也声明他大约在这个时间在房子外面停过。塞思说当时在下雨，所以他留在车里，在决定开车去金斯格罗夫拜访朋友之前，从来没有进过房子。然而，艾米丽·卢娜在接受采访时提供了两个关键细节，与塞思的供词相矛盾。首先，艾米丽清楚地记得她拜访房子时并没有下雨，因为她不需要使用雨伞。在与警方进一步交谈时，艾米丽还承认，她当时并没有看到塞思坐在车里。
The two suspected murder weapons, a knife believed to have been sourced from the Gonzalez kitchen and a baseball bat, had not been recovered. According to Seth's close friend Sam, Seth mentioned he kept a baseball bat in the boot of his car as a means of self-protection. When questioned about the bat, Seth said he may have carried one in the past, but he couldn't account for its current whereabouts. Investigators were certain Seth was being deceitful, but it wasn't until they began questioning his friends and extended social group that they uncovered the sheer extent of deception the 20-year-old had cultivated throughout the years. Seth gloated to acquaintances of being a Taekwondo expert who ran his own security company, owned property, and frequently traveled to New York to negotiate elaborate business deals. He also claimed to be the manager of a boy band, a music producer, a successful singer with a record deal, a world champion kickboxer, a lawyer, a personal trainer, and the manager of a modeling agency. In early 2000, Seth broke the news to friends that he had been diagnosed with cancer, later revealing he had beaten the disease and was now in remission. The depth of Seth's deception went far deeper than seemingly harmless arrogant brags to friends and associates.
两件疑似凶器——一把据信取自冈萨雷斯厨房的刀和一个棒球棍——尚未找到。根据塞思的好友萨姆所说，塞思曾提到他在汽车后备箱里放了一根棒球棍作为防身之用。当被问及这根棒球棍时，塞思说他过去可能带过一根，但他无法解释它现在的去向。调查人员确信塞思在说谎，但直到他们开始盘问他的朋友和扩大社交圈时，他们才发现这个20岁年轻人多年来编造的谎言规模有多大。塞思向熟人吹嘘自己是精通跆拳道并经营自己安保公司的专家、拥有房产，并经常前往纽约谈判复杂的商业交易。他还声称自己是一个男子乐队的经理、音乐制作人、拥有唱片合约的成功歌手、世界自由搏击冠军、律师、私人教练以及模特公司的经理。2000年初，塞思向朋友们爆料称自己被诊断出患有癌症，后来又透露他已经战胜了疾病并处于缓解期。塞思欺骗的深度远远超过了对朋友和同事看似无害的傲慢吹嘘。
Music was clearly Seth's greatest passion, yet his R&B group, Definite Vibes, had two staunch critics, his own parents. Teddy and Oliver were vocal about their disapproval of their son's musical ambitions as it had caused everything else in his life to fall by the wayside, including his education. Seth failed to submit assignments or attend exams, his musical priorities having irreversible negative impact on his medical science degree, which he hastily dropped out of. His parents threatened to take away his beloved car if his studies didn't improve, which would strip the 20-year-old of his independence. Teddy and Oliver were pleased when Seth started achieving high results in his new legal studies degree, indicating a positive change in his attitude. However, it was discovered Seth had been falsifying university documents to deceive his parents into thinking he was doing much better than he was. In reality, Seth was failing all four of his subjects. The truth about Seth's academic failure and forgery had only recently been exposed to Teddy and Oliver, their disappointment causing a rift between son and parents.
音乐显然是塞思最大的热情，但他的R&B组合“确定氛围”（Definite Vibes）有两个坚定的批评者——他自己的父母。泰迪和洛伊弗直言不讳地表达了他们对儿子音乐雄心的不赞成，因为这导致了他生活中的其他一切都被荒废了，包括他的教育。塞思未能按时交作业或参加考试，他的音乐优先事项对他的医学科学学位产生了不可逆转的负面影响，他匆忙退学了。他的父母威胁说，如果他的学业没有改善，就要收回他心爱的汽车，这将剥夺这个20岁年轻人的独立性。当塞思在他的新法律学位课程中取得高成绩时，泰迪和洛伊弗很高兴，这表明他的态度有了积极的转变。然而，人们发现塞思一直在伪造大学文件，以欺骗他的父母，让他们以为他比实际情况做得好得多。实际上，塞思的四门科目全都不及格。关于塞思学业失败和伪造的真相最近才被揭露给泰迪和洛伊弗，他们的失望导致了儿子与父母之间的裂痕。
Adding fuel to this tension was Seth's romantic relationships. He introduced one girlfriend to his mother in the hopes of gaining her approval, but loyver was dismissive, expressing concerns a girlfriend would only be another distraction to Seth's studies. Seth's parents threatened to disinherit him if he continued to see his girlfriend, leading the relationship to come to an end. Seth's temperamental relationship with his parents may have had roots in his upbringing. Although the Gonzales parents were loving, Seth was harshly disciplined when he misbehaved during his childhood. It appeared Seth carried the emotional baggage from his youth into his adult years, which manifested in frequent bedwetting. Loyver had encouraged Seth to seek professional help for this reoccurring issue, but her attempts to assist were futile. The true level of Seth's dishonesty was exposed when a family friend accused him of stealing money from her purse.
给这种紧张关系火上浇油的是塞思的恋爱关系。他把一个女朋友介绍给母亲，希望能得到母亲的批准，但洛伊弗却不屑一顾，表达了这样的担忧：女朋友只会分散塞思学业的精力。塞思的父母威胁说，如果他继续和这个女朋友交往，就要剥夺他的继承权，导致这段恋情走到了尽头。塞思与父母之间暴躁的关系可能植根于他的成长经历。虽然冈萨雷斯的父母很有爱心，但塞思在童年行为不端时受到了严厉的惩罚。塞思似乎把童年的情感包袱带到了成年期，这表现为频繁的夜尿症。洛伊弗曾鼓励塞思为这个反复出现的问题寻求专业帮助，但她试图提供的帮助是徒劳的。当一个家庭朋友指责塞思从她的钱包里偷钱时，塞思撒谎的真正程度暴露了。
Seth didn't deny the allegation, simply saying he was an opportunist. It came as little surprise to Teddy or Loyver when they found out, as they had suspected for some time that Seth was stealing cash from their wallets. After his parents and sister were murdered, Seth was approved a $15,000 payment from the government as part of a victims of crime compensation scheme. However, he didn't use this money to pay for his family's funeral or his own living expenses as it was intended. Instead, he used part of the payout for cosmetic enhancements to his mother's car, which he had taken to driving following her murder. The overwhelming circumstantial evidence was mounting against Seth Gonzales, who stood to gain immense profit from the deaths of his parents. Especially if his sister was removed from the equation. Seth vehemently denied accusations of involvement in the crime, alleging that a hit had been taken out on his family by one of his father's wealthy, influential Filipino business rivals.
塞思没有否认这一指控，只是说他是个机会主义者。当泰迪或洛伊弗发现时，他们并没有感到太意外，因为他们一段时间以来一直怀疑塞思在偷他们钱包里的现金。父母和妹妹被谋杀后，塞思根据犯罪受害者赔偿计划获得了政府1.5万澳元的批准金。然而，他并没有像原本打算的那样用这笔钱来支付家人的葬礼或他自己的生活费用。相反，他将部分赔偿金用于对母亲的汽车进行外观升级，自从母亲被谋杀后，他便开始开这辆车。压倒性的间接证据正在对塞思·冈萨雷斯不利，他将从父母的死中获得巨大的利益。特别是如果他的妹妹也被排除在方程式之外的话。塞思强烈否认参与这起犯罪的指控，声称他的家人是被他父亲的一个富有、有影响力的菲律宾商业竞争对手买凶杀害的。
Seth believed the killers intentionally spared one family member to serve as the scapegoat, and was living in fear that someone would be coming for him next. It wasn't a completely inconceivable prospect, as a colleague of Teddy's had overheard the immigration lawyer aggressively arguing and swearing on the phone with a Filipino property investor months prior to the murders. According to Teddy, the caller threatened to kill his family. But other than Teddy's word, investigators failed to find any concrete evidence to support this threat was ever made. They identified several business rivals of Teddy's who may have stood to gain marginally from his death. Yet, they lacked motive to order the deaths of Loewe and Claudine, and subsequent investigations ruled them out as suspects. Despite this, the hitman theory arose again in August, when Seth Gonzales handed police a copy of an anonymous email he had received a month after the murders. Written in a mix of English and Tagalog, the email stated a hitman was paid for three murders, and implied Seth had been the intended third target alongside his parents.
塞思认为凶手故意留下一名家庭成员作为替罪羊，并生活在恐惧之中，生怕有人会下一个找上他。这并非一个完全不可想象的前景，因为泰迪的一位同事曾听到这位移民律师在谋杀案发生前几个月，与一名菲律宾房地产投资者在电话里进行激烈的争吵和咒骂。据泰迪说，打电话的人威胁要杀死他的全家。但除了泰迪的一面之词外，调查人员未能找到任何具体证据来支持这一威胁曾经被发出过。他们确定了几位泰迪的商业竞争对手，这些人可能从他的死中获得微薄的利益。然而，他们缺乏下令杀害洛伊弗和克劳丁的动机，随后的调查排除了他们作为嫌疑人的可能。尽管如此，杀手理论在8月再次出现，当时塞思·冈萨雷斯向警方交出了一份他在谋杀案发生一个月后收到的一封匿名电子邮件的复印件。这封邮件由英文和他加禄语混写，称杀手为三起谋杀案获得了报酬，并暗示塞思是除了他父母之外的第三个预定目标。
The email read, You're supposed to be the third person. They were paid for three. It's a blessing that you were not there. Seth was convinced his life was still in danger, enlisting friends to act as bodyguards. Police later seized Seth's personal computers and found a draft of the threatening email stored on one of them. Seth had written it himself. Seth's aunt, Emily Luna, refused to accept that her baby-faced nephew could be guilty for the violent triple murder, despite recognizing many inconsistencies in his statements and having some awareness that he was not the perfect son. Nevertheless, Emily remained supportive of Seth, even holding his hand as he gave his first interview with police regarding July 10. Emily listened as Seth detailed driving to the Gonzales house at 6pm before departing soon after.
邮件写道：“你应该是第三个人。他们付了三个人的钱。你不在那里真是一种保佑。”塞思确信自己的生命仍然处于危险之中，于是招募朋友充当保镖。警方后来查获了塞思的个人电脑，并在其中一台电脑上发现了一份威胁邮件的草稿。塞思是自己写的。塞思的姑姑艾米丽·卢娜拒绝接受她那娃娃脸的侄子会是这起暴力三起谋杀案的凶手，尽管她承认他的供词中有许多矛盾之处，并且意识到他并不是完美的儿子。尽管如此，艾米丽仍然支持塞思，甚至在他接受关于7月10日的第一次警方采访时握着他的手。艾米丽听着塞思详细描述他在下午6点开车去冈萨雷斯家，不久后便离开的经过。
It was his remark that the rain prevented him from getting out of his car that caused Emily's hand to instinctively jerk away from Seth's. She stopped by the house at 6pm and knew without a doubt that it had not been raining, and Seth was not in his car. It was in that moment the haunting realization dawned on Emily. She knew her nephew was lying. Upon accepting the possibility that Seth may be responsible for the brutal murder of her sister, brother-in-law and niece, Emily agreed to discreetly work with investigators against her nephew. A listening device was installed in her car and a plan constructed in which she was to tell Seth she knew he was responsible for the killings and wanted to protect him. But the ploy didn't work. Not only did Seth continually deny having anything to do with the crime, he also told Emily he was so depressed over the matter that he was considering taking his own life. Two months after the murders of Teddy, Lover and Claudine Gonzales, Seth was at a coffee shop when a passer-by complimented him on his clothing. Flattered, Seth struck up a conversation with a man who revealed himself to be a gangster with connections to the police force.
正是他关于“雨水阻止了他下车”的言论，让艾米丽的手本能地从塞思的手中抽开。她在下午6点顺道去了那栋房子，并且百分之百确定当时根本没有下雨，塞思也根本不在他的车里。就在那一刻，令人挥之不去的 realization 黎明般在艾米丽脑海中浮现。她知道她的侄子在说谎。在接受了塞思可能对她的姐姐、姐夫和侄女的残酷谋杀负责的可能性后，艾米丽同意秘密与调查人员合作，对抗她的侄子。一个监听设备被安装在她的车里，并制定了一个计划：她要告诉塞思，她知道他是这些谋杀案的幕后黑手，并且想要保护他。但这个计策没有奏效。塞思不仅不断否认与这起犯罪有任何关系，他还告诉艾米丽，他对此事感到非常沮丧，以至于正在考虑结束自己的生命。泰迪、洛伊弗和克劳丁·冈萨雷斯被谋杀两个月后，塞思正在一家咖啡馆里，一个路人称赞了他的衣着。塞思深受奉承，便和一个自称是与警方有联系的黑帮分子的男子攀谈起来。
Seth claimed he too was in a gang called the White Dragons Asian. In truth, there was no such gang. Seth made it up. The two build a rapport, forming a friendship over the following weeks. The man was aware of the allegations Seth was facing and in an act of good faith offered his new friend an opportunity. He knew a guy in prison who was dying and who was willing to take the rap for crimes he didn't commit. If Seth wanted to, the terminal prisoner could confess to the Gonzales family murders on Seth's behalf, taking the heat off him completely. In the end, Seth didn't accept the offer, only going so far as providing the gangster with hand-drawn floor plans at the Gonzales home, marked with the location where each member of his family was found. Unbeknownst to Seth, his gangster friend was actually an undercover police officer.
塞思声称自己也加入了一个名为“亚洲白龙”（White Dragons Asian）的帮派。事实上，根本没有这样的帮派。是塞思编造的。两人一拍即合，在接下来的几周里建立了友谊。这名男子知道塞思面临的指控，出于善意，他为新朋友提供了一个机会。他认识监狱里的一个人快死了，愿意为一个他没有犯下的罪行顶罪。如果塞思愿意，这个身患绝症的囚犯可以代表塞思承认冈萨雷斯一家的谋杀案，从而彻底消除他的压力。最后，塞思并没有接受这个提议，只是向黑帮分子提供了冈萨雷斯家手绘的平面图，上面标明了找到他家人中每个成员的位置。塞思不知道的是，他的黑帮朋友实际上是一名卧底警察。
Police promptly compared Seth's handwriting from the map provided to the undercover officer so the racist graffiti on the internal wall of the Gonzales house and found slight similarities between the two. That wasn't the only valuable piece of information Seth had unwittingly provided. On the floor plan, he had also noted the time of death of each family member. Information police had intentionally withheld, as it was a detail only the killer would know. During the surveillance, Seth told the undercover officer, People don't suspect me. It's just Seth with the little baby face. I have a split personality. I can hide what I do. They've got nothing on me. It's all circumstantial stuff. However, as the undercover operation progressed, Seth didn't confess, telling the undercover officer he was not involved in the murders and maintaining his story that a contract killer hired by one of his father's rivals was responsible for the crime.
警方迅速将地图上塞思的笔迹与冈萨雷斯家内墙上的种族主义涂鸦进行对比，发现两者有微小的相似之处。这并不是塞思无意中提供的唯一有价值的信息。在平面图上，他还标注了每个家庭成员的死亡时间。这是警方故意隐瞒的信息，因为这是只有凶手才知道的细节。在监视期间，塞思告诉卧底警官：“人们不怀疑我。这只是有着娃娃脸的塞思。我有分裂人格。我可以隐藏我所做的事情。他们抓不到我的把柄。这都是些间接的东西。”然而，随着卧底行动的进展，塞思并没有坦白，他告诉卧底警官他没有参与谋杀，并坚称是受雇于他父亲竞争对手之一的职业杀手对这起犯罪负责的故事。
Seth's personal computer had been confiscated from the crime scene and an examination of its contents revealed a disturbing internet history. In the months leading up to the triple murder, searches were made online for poisons that could be easily disguised within food. An online purchase was made for the seeds of two types of highly lethal plants from a United States supplier, delivery expected in early July. The website of an Australian based seed supplier had also been visited, but their orders were temporarily unavailable. An email had been sent from Seth's computer to this supplier, requesting they make an exception, explaining it was his mother's 60th birthday the following weekend and he wanted to buy the seeds as a present. The email read, She has been looking for those particular seeds ever since she saw them in Florida last year. This email was misleading on two accounts.
塞思的个人电脑从犯罪现场被没收，对其内容的检查揭示了一段令人不安的互联网历史。在三起谋杀案发生前的几个月里，网上曾搜索过可以轻松伪装在食物中的毒药。有人从一家美国供应商那里在线购买了两种剧毒植物的种子，预计在7月初交货。一家澳大利亚本地种子供应商的网站也曾被访问过，但他们的订单暂时缺货。塞思的电脑曾向这家供应商发送了一电子邮件，要求他们通融一下，解释说下周末是他母亲的60岁生日，他想买这些种子作为礼物。邮件写道：“自从她去年在佛罗里达看到这些种子以来，她一直在寻找那些特定的种子。”这封电子邮件在两个方面具有误导性。
Lover Gonzalez was only 43 years old, not 60, and she had not recently travelled to Florida. Seth denied performing the searches, ordering the seeds or sending the email, pinning the actions on his deceased father, claiming Teddy must have been researching the seeds online to ensure he didn't plan anything poisonous in the garden. Unbeknownst to Seth, police had found a vial of clear liquid taped under his desk during an earlier search of his bedroom. Scientific testing revealed the mysterious liquid to be a poisonous substance derived from one of the plants searched for online, highly lethal to anyone who consumed it. Days before her murder, Lover Gonzalez had been admitted to hospital after suffering from intense fever and severe abdominal pains. She suspected the culprit was undercooked food she consumed whilst dining out with her family, as Seth had also complained of feeling unwell after the meal. As such, she was diagnosed with colitis, an inflammation of the bowel associated with food poisoning. Lover received treatment and was discharged from hospital after an overnight stay.
洛伊弗·冈萨雷斯当时只有43岁，而不是60岁，而且她最近也没有去过佛罗里达。塞思否认自己曾进行过搜索、订购种子或发送电子邮件，并将这些行为归咎于他已故的父亲，声称泰迪一定是在网上研究种子，以确保他没有在花园里种植任何有毒的东西。塞思并不知道，警方在早期对他的卧室进行搜查时，在他的书桌下发现了一瓶用胶带固定住的透明液体。科学检测表明，这种神秘液体是从网上搜索过的植物中提取的有毒物质，对任何食用它的人来说都是剧毒。在她被谋杀几天前，洛伊弗·冈萨雷斯因遭受高烧和剧烈腹痛而被送往医院。她怀疑罪魁祸首是她与家人外出用餐时食用的未煮熟的食物，因为塞思也抱怨说饭后感觉不舒服。因此，她被诊断患有结肠炎，这是一种与食物中毒相关的肠道炎症。洛伊弗接受了治疗，并在住院一夜后出院。
The link between the purchase of the poisonous seeds and Lover's sudden illness was not lost on investigators, who were coming to realise that the deaths of the Gonzalez family may have been months in the planning. The poisons weren't the only troublesome discovery within the internet history of Seth's computer. Frequent visits were also made to the webpage operated by Seth's number one fan, teenager Daisy Diaz, where she boasted about her love for the singer and raved about his outstanding personality, good looks and incredible talents. When investigators questioned Seth about his relationship with Daisy, he revealed she had recently passed away during the September 11 terrorist attacks on the World Trade Center. Seth claimed he had flown to New York City with Daisy's mother to attend the funeral. But investigators soon learned the truth. Daisy Diaz didn't exist. Her dedication page to Sethie and all its gushing posts of adoration was created and managed by Seth himself. In September 2001, Seth's relatives were left shaken and distraught when he broke the devastating news that he had been diagnosed with a brain tumour.
购买有毒种子与洛伊弗突然生病之间的联系并没有逃过调查人员的眼睛，他们开始意识到冈萨雷斯一家的死可能在几个月前就已经在策划了。毒药并不是塞思电脑互联网历史中唯一令人不安的发现。人们还频繁访问由塞思的头号粉丝、十几岁的黛西·迪亚兹（Daisy Diaz）运营的网页，她在网页上吹嘘自己对这位歌手的爱，并对他出色的个性、长相和不可思议的才华赞不绝口。当调查人员就他与黛西的关系盘问塞思时，他透露她在9·11世界贸易中心恐怖袭击事件中最近不幸遇难。塞思声称自己和黛西的母亲一起飞往纽约市参加葬礼。但调查人员很快得知了真相。黛西·迪亚兹根本不存在。她为塞思设立的奉献页面以及所有那些充满崇拜的帖子都是塞思自己创建和管理的。2001年9月，塞思的亲戚们在他爆出自己被诊断出患有脑瘤的毁灭性消息时，感到震惊和心烦意乱。
He contacted his aunt Annie to inform her of the grim diagnosis, requesting she sent him $190,000 to pay for life-saving surgery. Annie, who was responsible for managing Teddy's overseas investment properties, was immediately suspicious of her nephew's claims. She refused his monetary request, instead informing the police about her concerns. By this stage, Seth had not yet gained access to his deceased family's multi-million dollar estate and his request for further victim compensation payments had been refused by the government. Seth did manage to amass approximately $88,000 by selling his parents' cars, his mother's jewellery, and his beloved Ford Festiva. In the following month of October, Seth placed the deposit on a $175,000 Lexus SC 430, telling the car dealership he would pay the remaining balance when his inheritance money came through. Seth eventually had to cancel the order for the Lexus as he was unable to come up with the remaining balance. He purchased the more affordable car instead, personalizing the license plate to read TLCS, the initials of the first names of his immediate family.
他联系了他的阿姨安妮，将严峻的诊断结果通知她，并请求她寄给他19万澳元来支付挽救生命的的手术费用。负责管理泰迪海外投资房产的安妮立即对她侄子的说法产生怀疑。她拒绝了他的金钱请求，转而将她的担忧告知了警方。在这个阶段，塞思还没有获得他已故家人的数百万美元遗产，政府也拒绝了他对进一步受害者赔偿金的请求。塞思确实通过出售父母的汽车、母亲的珠宝以及他心爱的福特福斯蒂瓦，聚敛了大约8.8万澳元。在接下来的10月，塞思为一辆价值17.5万澳元的雷克萨斯SC 430支付了定金，并告诉汽车经销商，等他的遗产资金到账时，他会支付剩余的尾款。塞思最终不得不取消雷克萨斯的订单，因为他拿不出剩余的尾款。相反，他购买了一辆更实惠的汽车，并将车牌个性化定制为“TLCS”，即他直系亲属名字的首字母缩写。
Since the murders, Seth moved between relatives' homes before he finally settled into a rental apartment on the 11th floor of a secured building in the North Shore suburb of Chatswood. The apartment's rent and bills were financed by his relatives, and Seth furnished it with property taken from his family's Collins Street home. He told relatives police recommended the relocation as a safety proportion, which was entirely untrue. In December, Seth's aunt, Emily Luna, agreed to attend the Gonzales residence to re-enact her version of events from the evening of July 10. Emily had arrived to the house at 6pm, with the impression someone was home. She spotted Seth's Ford Festiva in the carport and noticed it was empty. She had seen what she believed was a figure wearing a baseball cap and coat on the other side of the front door, standing in the foyer. But her young son had convinced her it was just a coat stand.
谋杀案发生后，塞思在亲戚的家之间辗转，直到最后安顿在北岸查茨伍德郊区一栋戒备森严的大楼11楼的一套出租公寓里。这套公寓的租金和账单由他的亲戚资助，塞思用从他家人柯林斯街家中拿走的财产布置了它。他告诉亲戚，警察建议将搬迁作为安全预防措施，这完全是谎言。12月，塞思的姑姑艾米丽·卢娜同意前往冈萨雷斯住宅，重新演绎她对7月10日晚事情经过的看法。艾米丽于下午6点到达房子，带着家里有人的印象。她在车棚里看到了塞思的福特福斯蒂瓦，并注意到它是空的。她看到她认为是穿着棒球帽和外套的身影站在前门另一侧的门厅里。但她的小儿子说服她那只是一个衣帽架。
During the December re-enactment, Emily realized the coat stand in the foyer was actually situated much further back from the front door than she originally thought. Emily was now certain it was a person she saw on the other side of the door that night, five foot, four inches tall, the same height as Seth Gonzales. By January 2002, Seth was made aware that investigators were doubting his alibi for the night of the murders. The Daily Telegraph newspaper reported that police were now following a line of inquiry around a green hatchback, similar to Seth's Ford Festiva. The undercover officer, still posing as Seth's gangster friend, also intentionally leaked information to Seth that witnesses had cited his empty vehicle at the front of his house on the afternoon of the murders. Seth was oblivious to the fact his phones were bugged and his calls were being monitored and recorded by police. During a phone call to a friend dated January 10, Seth admitted his original alibi on the night of the murders had been a lie, but he had a new one that he was certain would convince police of his innocence, although he admitted he was worried it could, quote, blow up in his face again. After this call, police confronted Seth about his alibi and he decided to come clean.
在12月的案情重演期间，艾米丽意识到门厅里的衣帽架实际上比她最初想象的离前门要远得多. 艾米丽现在确信，那天晚上她在门另一侧看到的是一个人，身高五英尺四英寸，与赛斯·冈萨雷斯身高相同. 到2002年1月，赛斯开始意识到调查人员在怀疑他谋杀当晚的不在场证明. 《每日电讯报》报道称，警方目前正围绕一辆绿色两厢车展开调查，这与赛斯的福特Festiva相似. 这名仍在冒充赛斯黑帮朋友的便衣警察，还故意向赛斯透露信息，称有目击者在谋杀案发生当天下午看到他的空车停在房前. 赛斯并不知道他的电话被窃听，他的通话也一直受到警方的监控和录音. 在1月10日打给朋友的一通电话中，赛斯承认他最初关于谋杀当晚的不在场证明是个谎言，但他有了一个新证明，他确信这能让警方相信他是无辜的，尽管他承认自己担心这可能会“再次搞砸”. 在这通电话后，警方就他的不在场证明与赛斯进行了对质，他决定坦白.
Seth did not go driving around Kingsgrove looking for his friend's new house on the night of the murders. He had actually visited a sex worker. He wasn't upfront about it initially as he was concerned the act could bring shame upon his religious family, who believed he was a virgin. Seth now claimed that on the evening of the murders, he left his father's legal office just before 4pm. He parked his car at home before walking to a nearby petrol station where he caught a taxi to a brothel located in Chatswood. He left his car at home because he didn't want to risk someone citing it near the brothel. Seth engaged in the services of a sex worker and boasted she tried to refuse his payment because the sex was so good. Afterwards, Seth walked to Chatswood train station where he caught a taxi back home to Collins Street. He got straight into his car and drove to his friend Sam's place for their scheduled 8pm meetup.
谋杀当晚，赛斯并没有开车在金斯格罗夫寻找他朋友的新房子. 他实际上是去找了一名性工作者. 起初他没有直说，是因为担心这种行为会给他的宗教家庭带来耻辱，因为他的家人一直认为他是处男. 赛斯现在声称，在谋杀案当晚，他在下午4点前不久离开了父亲的律师事务所. 他把车停在家裡，然后步行到一个附近的加油站，在那里坐出租车去了一家位于查茨伍德的妓院. 他把车留在家里，是因为他不想冒着被人看到车停在妓院附近的风险. 赛斯接受了一名性工作者的服务，并吹嘘说对方甚至想免收他的服务费，因为他表现太好了. 此后，赛斯步行到查茨伍德火车站，坐出租车回到了科林斯街的家中. 他直接上车，开车去了朋友萨姆的家，参加他们原定晚上8点举行的聚会.
As they continued to monitor Seth's phone calls, police were aware that Seth had recently been contacting numerous brothels in the North Shore area. Around the same time, they noticed he was having telecommunications with an unknown male. Officers tracked down this man and paid him a visit to inquire about his relationship with Seth and the purpose of their recent phone calls. The man was a local taxi driver. He revealed Seth had approached him at the taxi rank at Chatswood train station on January 12, 2002, 5 months after the triple murder. Seth offered the taxi driver $50 to write a formal statement confirming that he had picked Seth up on the evening of July 10, 2001 and had dropped him off at a brothel. Seth reassured the taxi driver the request didn't relate to anything serious. When police informed the driver that Seth was implicated in a triple homicide, he immediately retracted his statement, which was just as well as his driving records for the evening of July 10 failed to support Seth's new alibi.
随着警方继续监听赛斯的电话，他们发现赛斯最近一直在联系北岸地区的许多妓院. 大约在同一时间，他们注意到他与一名身份不明的男性有通讯往来. 警官们找到了这名男子，并登门拜访，询问他与赛斯的关系以及他们最近频繁通话的目的. 这名男子是一名当地的出租车司机. 他透露，在2002年1月12日，即三起谋杀案发生5个月后，赛斯曾在查茨伍德火车站的出租车排队处接近他. 赛斯给这名出租车司机50美元，让他写一份正式声明，证实他在2001年7月10日晚上接了赛斯，并把他送到了一家妓院. 赛斯向出租车司机保证，这个要求不涉及任何严重的事情. 当警方告知司机赛斯卷入了一起三亚谋杀案时，他立即撤回了自己的声明，这也正好印证了他在7月10日晚上的驾驶记录无法支持赛斯的新不在场证明.
By early April, police had spoken with the sex worker Seth claimed to have been with the evening of July 10, who revealed she had not been working at the brothel that night. Since the slayings, Seth had been harassing the woman, sending her over 100 text messages in an attempt to convince her to say they had been together that night. On May 30, Seth contacted police to report a break-in at his Chatswood apartment. He also told them he had received two threatening emails, one which warned him, quote, Make it easy on yourself. Confess to the police now. Your father deserved to die. Don't talk to reporters. Police found no evidence at the apartment to support Seth's claims that a break-in had occurred. They traced the location where the threatening emails had been sent, determining their origin to have been an internet cafe in Sydney. As there was no CCTV footage inside the cafe, the sender could not be identified.
到4月初，警方已经与赛斯声称在7月10日晚上陪伴他的性工作者进行了交谈，她透露自己当晚根本没有在那家妓院工作. 自命案发生以来，赛斯一直骚扰这名女子，给她发送了100多条短信，试图说服她说他们那天晚上是在一起的. 5月30日，赛斯联系警方，报案称他在查茨伍德的公寓遭到入室盗窃. 他还告诉警方，他收到了两封威胁邮件，其中一封警告他：“对自己好过一点. 马上向警方自首. 你的父亲死有余辜. 不要跟记者说话.”警方在公寓里没有发现任何证据来支持赛斯关于发生入室盗窃的说法. 他们追踪了发送威胁邮件的地点，确定其源头是悉尼的一家网吧. 由于网吧内没有闭路电视监控画面，发送者的身份无法确定.
With media interest heightened around Seth, he offered to speak to journalists for a fee, claiming his safety was at risk and he needed money to hire a bodyguard. When he realized that asking for payment for an interview about his family's slaughter was a bad look, Seth agreed to chat with journalist Cara Lawrence from the Daily Telegraph newspaper for free. During his interview with Lawrence, Seth reiterated his suspicion that his family's killer had been responsible for the break-in at his apartment. He declined to say whether he had given police any specific information about who he suspected was responsible for the murders and subsequent break-in, but concluded, quote, I know that somewhere out there, there is someone who knows something about someone who's afraid to speak out for whatever understandable reasons. I'm sure the police would do whatever they can to assist whoever is brave enough to come forward with information. Cara Lawrence later detailed this interview along with her investigations into the case for her book titled Unmasked, The Gonzales Family Killer. At 8.30pm that night, Seth was found lying in a gutter in Chatswood, a plastic bag was found beside him.
随着媒体对赛斯的关注度不断升温，他提出有偿接受记者采访，声称自己的人身安全受到威胁，需要钱来雇佣保镖. 当他意识到为了家人被屠杀一事索要采访费的做法很不光彩时，赛斯同意免费与《每日电讯报》的记者卡拉·劳伦斯交谈. 在接受劳伦斯采访时，赛斯重申了他此前的怀疑，即杀害他家人的凶手也是他公寓入室盗窃案的幕后黑手. 他拒绝透露自己是否向警方提供过任何具体信息，说明他怀疑谁是谋杀案和随后的入室盗窃案的幕后黑手，但他总结道：“我知道在这个世界的某个地方，总有人了解某些内幕，但出于某种可以理解的原因，他们不敢说出来. 我相信警方会尽一切所能，协助任何有勇气站出来提供线索的人.”卡拉·劳伦斯后来在她的书《揭面：冈萨雷斯家族杀手》中详细记录了这次采访以及她对该案的调查. 当天晚上8点30分，赛斯被发现躺在查茨伍德的一个排水沟里，他身边有一个塑料袋.
Seth was rushed to hospital where he told doctors he couldn't remember who he was or what year it was. Despite his apparent memory loss, there was no evidence indicating Seth had sustained any head trauma. After he supposedly regained his memory, Seth made a police report alleging that he had been abducted whilst walking down the street. Someone had pulled him into a car, covered his head with a plastic bag and hit him across the head with something resembling a piece of wood. The abductors warned him to withdraw the reward money he had offered to the public for information on his family's killers. They also demanded he stop speaking to the media, otherwise there would be serious consequences for his extended family, especially his grandmother and the leader. Further investigations into this alleged crime came up empty. There was no proof it took place. With Seth specifically singling out threats against his grandmother, police became concerned for Amelida's safety.
赛斯被紧急送往医院，他在那里告诉医生，他记不清自己是谁，也记不清今年是哪一年了. 尽管他表现出明显的失忆，但没有证据表明赛斯受过任何头部外伤. 在他所谓的恢复记忆后，赛斯向警方报案，声称他在街上行走时遭到绑架. 有人把他拉进一辆车里，用塑料袋套住他的头，并用类似于木块的东西击打他的头部. 绑架者警告他撤回悬赏金，这笔赏金原本是他为获取家人遇害线索而向公众提供的. 他们还要求他停止接受媒体采访，否则他的大家庭，尤其是他的祖母和领袖，将会面临严重的后果. 经对这起所谓犯罪行为的进一步调查，结果一无所获. 没有任何证据表明此事发生过. 由于赛斯专门挑出针对祖母的威胁，警方开始为阿梅利达的安全感到担忧.
Worried Seth would put anyone in harm's way in order to deflect suspicion from himself. On June 13, 2002, police executed a search warrant on Seth's Chatswood apartment and charged him with three counts of murder. As per protocol, Seth's fingerprints were taken and entered into the police database. The database revealed they matched to a previously unidentified fingerprint that was found on an envelope of a letter sent to a food manufacturer on July 2, 2001. The threatening letter claimed the manufacturer's products had been contaminated with deadly poison. The letter stated, three of your products have been poisoned, but now they are on supermarket shelves. This is what you get for treating employees like garbage. Good luck finding infected cans before someone dies. Go to hell. Australian Federal Police entered the Australian Quarantine and Inspection Service, received similar letters around that time.
由于担心赛斯会为了洗脱自己的嫌疑而不择手段地将任何人置于危险之中，2002年6月13日，警方对赛斯的查茨伍德公寓执行了搜查令，并以三项谋杀罪对其实施指控. 按照程序，警方提取了赛斯的指纹并将其输入警察数据库. 数据库显示，这些指纹与此前未确认身份的指纹相吻合，该指纹是在2001年7月2日寄给一家食品制造商的信件信封上发现的. 这封威胁信声称该制造商的产品受到了致命毒物的污染. 信中写道：“你们的三种产品已经有毒，但现在它们已经摆上了超市的货架. 这就是把员工当垃圾对待的下场. 祝你们在有人死亡之前好运，能找到被污染的罐头. 下地狱吧.”澳大利亚联邦警察在进入澳大利亚检疫检验服务局时，在同期也收到了类似的信件.
Their letters claimed to be from concerned food production employees who had received an anonymous tip-off advising that some of the company's products had been poisoned. Traces of all three letters, along with an online search history for the addresses of all recipients, were found on Seth Gonzalez's laptop. Police believed the letters were residue of Seth's initial plan to poison his family to death, going so far as to fabricating evidence to redirect any suspicion away from himself. Along with murder, Seth was also charged with threatening product contamination. Seth's grandmother, Amelida and Aunt Emily both openly spoke about their fear of Seth during his bail application. Bail was rejected on the basis that Seth was considered too strong a flight risk. Two months later, Seth launched an application to gain access to his parents' estate in order to fund his trial defence, but the request was denied. The trial for the murders of Teddy, Lover and Claudine Gonzalez commenced in early April 2004, with Seth's defence funded by Legal Aid, legal representation given to defendants who cannot afford their own.
他们的信件声称来自对食品生产感到担忧的员工，这些员工收到了匿名举报，称该公司的一些产品受到了污染. 警方在赛斯·冈萨雷斯的笔记本电脑上找到了这三封信件的痕迹，以及所有收件人地址的在线搜索记录. 警方认为，这些信件是赛斯最初毒死家人计划的残留证据，他甚至不惜伪造证据，以转移任何指向自己的怀疑. 除了谋杀罪，赛斯还被控威胁进行产品污染. 赛斯的祖母阿梅利达和姑姑艾米丽在保释听证会上都公开表达了对赛斯的恐惧. 法院以赛斯有极高的潜逃风险为由驳回了保释申请. 两个月后，赛斯提出申请，希望动用父母的遗产来支付审判辩护费用，但遭到拒绝. 泰迪、洛弗和克劳丁·冈萨雷斯谋杀案的审判于2004年4月初正式开始，赛斯的辩护费用由法律援助（即为无法承担费用的被告提供的法律代理）资助.
The lesser charge of threatening product contamination would only precede the trial if Seth was found not guilty of the murders. Seth testified during the trial, fielding questions from senior crown prosecutor Mark Tedeschi, who argued Seth had spent several months planning the murders of his family, as premeditation was evident in his attempt to poison Lover Gonzalez in early July. The many lies Seth had told friends and family about his movements on the night of the murders were put before the court, corroborated by the information provided by Seth himself during over 8000 phone calls police had covertly monitored. As further proof of Seth's habit of lying to protect himself, the prosecution also alleged that the defendants' claims he had been abducted, assaulted and left for dead in the gutter in Chatswood was yet another ruse to fool police. The prosecution maintained that Seth murdered his parents amid fears of their incoming punishment for failing his second university course, fully aware that their first act of discipline would be to confiscate his beloved car. His motive for murdering Claudine was more personal, perhaps indicating why she was also bludgeoned. It was known Claudine was the one who had told Teddy and Lover about Seth faking his university results. Seth's greed was another motivating factor in the slaughter of his sister, driven by his desire to be the sole beneficiary of his parents' multi-million dollar estate.
只有在赛斯被裁定谋杀罪不成立的情况下，威胁产品污染这一较轻的罪名才会进入审判程序. 赛斯在审判期间出庭作证，并回答了高级皇家检察官马克·特德斯基的质询. 特德斯基指出，赛斯花了几个月时间策划谋杀家人，因为他在7月初试图毒害洛弗·冈萨雷斯的行为清楚地表明了其预谋性. 赛斯此前就其在谋杀当晚的行踪向朋友和家人撒过的无数谎言被提交法庭，这些谎言得到了警方秘密监控的8000多通电话中赛斯自己提供的信息的证实. 为了进一步证明赛斯为保护自己而撒谎的习惯，控方还指控被告声称自己被绑架、袭击并在查茨伍德的排水沟里等死的说法，不过是又一个愚弄警方的把戏. 控方坚称，赛斯因害怕父母得知他第二次大学课程不及格而对其进行惩罚，进而谋杀了父母，他完全清楚父母采取的第一项纪律处分就是没收他心爱的汽车. 他谋杀克劳丁的动机则更为私人，这或许解释了她为什么也会遭到重击. 众所周知，正是克劳丁把赛斯伪造大学成绩的事告诉了泰迪和洛弗. 贪婪是导致赛斯残杀妹妹的另一个动机，因为他渴望成为父母数百万美元遗产的唯一受益人.
Based on evidence and forensic findings, the prosecution concluded that on the afternoon of July 10, 2001, Seth Gonzalez returned home after working at his parents' legal office. He collected the baseball bat he had kept in the boot of his car, as well as two large knives from the kitchen. Wearing gloves, her coat and her hat, he went upstairs to Claudine's bedroom. He surprised the teen as she sat at her desk studying, bludgeoning, throttling, then stabbing her to death. After murdering his younger sister, Seth covered her brutalised body with a red jacket. He then headed downstairs and laying in wait for his mother to arrive home. At approximately 6pm, Seth confronted Lover as she entered the living space, stabbing her to death. He then waited in the foyer for his father to return home.
根据证据和法医勘验结果，控方得出结论：2001年7月10日下午，赛斯·冈萨雷斯在父母的律师事务所工作完后回到了家. 他拿走了放在汽车后备箱里的棒球棍，以及厨房里的两把大刀. 他戴上手套，穿着大衣和帽子，径直走上楼来到克劳丁的卧室. 当时这名少女正坐在书桌前学习，他突然袭击了她，先是用钝器击打、勒住她的脖子，最后将其刺死. 在谋杀了他年轻的妹妹后，赛斯用一件红色夹克盖住了她那遭到残酷虐待的尸体. 随后他下楼，潜伏在家中等待母亲回家. 大约晚上6点，赛斯在洛弗进入起居空间时与其对质，将其刺死. 接着，他在门厅里等候父亲回家.
Within this time frame, Emily Luna visited the Gonzalez house and inadvertently saw Seth through the frosted glass by the front door in his baseball cap and coat. Teddy arrived home at around 7pm, where he was immediately killed by Seth upon entering the house. After the murders, Seth showered and got changed and proceeded to stage the scene to look like a racially motivated break-in and robbery. He graffitied the walls with racial slurs, accidentally leaving evidence of the blue spray paint on his jumper sleeve. Previous testing had confirmed the blue staining on Seth's jumper was indeed paint, but it was revealed during the trial that it was an exact match for the paint used for the graffiti. After staging the scene, Seth left the house in his car to dispose of the kitchen knives, baseball bat, spray can, shoes and clothing he was wearing at the time of the murders, items which have never been recovered. He then went to pick up his friend Sam, ensuring they hung out at a crowded area with plenty of security cameras to solidify his alibi. When he returned home later that evening, he called triple zero, feigning hysterics at finding his family murdered.
正是在这段时间内，艾米丽·露娜拜访了冈萨雷斯家，无意中透过前门旁边的磨砂玻璃看到了戴着棒球帽和穿大衣的赛斯. 泰迪于晚上7点左右回到家，一进门就被赛斯当场杀害. 谋杀发生后，赛斯洗了个澡，换了衣服，并着手将现场伪装成一起带有种族仇视动机的入室抢劫案. 他在墙上喷涂了带有种族歧视色彩的侮辱性词汇，却不小心在套头衫的袖子上留下了蓝色喷漆的证据. 此前的检测已证实，赛斯套头衫上的蓝色污渍确实是油漆，而在审判期间证实，这与涂鸦所使用的油漆完全吻合. 伪装现场后，赛斯开车离开家，去处理厨房刀具、棒球棍、喷漆罐、鞋子以及他在谋杀时穿的衣物，这些物品至今未被找到. 随后他去接朋友萨姆，确保两人在一个有大量监控摄像头的人群密集区域闲逛，以稳固他的不在场证明. 当天深夜回到家后，他拨打了三个零（紧急报警电话），假装歇斯底里地发现家人被谋杀.
But no matter how much Seth carried on, he couldn't even manage to fake a single tear to sell his performance to attending police officers. Seth Gonzalez was the only witness for the defense. During cross-examination, he confessed his first alibi was a liar driven out of panic and embarrassment from admitting the truth of visiting a brothel. He also revealed he had lied in many other instances during the investigation, confirming it was he who researched and ordered the poison seeds online. He also admitted he authored the threatening emails he allegedly received from his family's killer. On May 20, 2004, the jury found Seth Gonzalez guilty of the murders of Teddy, Lover and Claudine Gonzalez. Seth was visibly shocked when the verdict was announced. Outside court, his aunt Annie said,
然而，无论赛斯如何表演，他甚至无法挤出一滴眼泪来向出警的警官证明自己的悲伤. 赛斯·冈萨雷斯是辩方唯一的证人. 在接受盘问时，他坦白自己最初的不在场证明是个谎言，这是出于对承认自己去过妓院这一真相的恐慌和尴尬. 他还透露，在调查过程中的许多其他情况下他也撒了谎，并证实正是他在网上搜索并订购了毒树种. 他还承认，那些他声称收到的来自家人凶手的威胁邮件其实是由他本人撰写的. 2004年5月20日，陪审团裁定赛斯·冈萨雷斯谋杀泰迪、洛弗和克劳丁·冈萨雷斯的罪名成立. 宣读裁决时，赛斯显得十分震惊. 在法庭外，他的姑姑安妮说道：
I just feel that we have lost another member of the family. We're really in pain. I think justice has been done, but it would have been easier to accept if it were a different person. It's just so hard to accept. I just wish it wasn't him. During sentencing on August 27, 2004, victim impact statements from the Gonzalez's extended family were read out to the court. Lover's sister Annie spoke of the relief that their cry for justice had been answered, but added it came with profound sadness wrapped in sorrow and tears. Seth's grandmother, Amelida, also prepared a victim impact statement, part of which read, To this day, I am struggling to cope with the emotional pain and trauma of what has happened. I miss all of them every day. Psychiatry professor David Greenberg was tasked with concluding whether Seth had any mitigating psychiatric illness that could have contributed to the crimes. Professor Greenberg concluded there was insufficient evidence to suggest the diagnosis.
“我只觉得我们失去了家庭的另一个成员. 我们真的很痛苦. 我认为正义得到了伸张，但如果换作另一个人，这或许会更容易接受. 这一切实在太难接受了. 我只希望凶手不是他.”在2004年8月27日的量刑听证会上，冈萨雷斯家族远亲们的受害人影响陈述被宣读给法庭. 洛弗的姐姐安妮谈到了他们对正义的呼唤得到回应时的宽慰，但她补充说，这种宽慰伴随着深深的悲伤，被悲痛和泪水所包裹. 赛斯的祖母阿梅利达也准备了一份受害人影响陈述，其中部分内容写道：“直到今天，我仍在艰难应对事情发生带来的情感痛苦和创伤. 我每天都在想念他们所有人.”精神病学教授大卫·格林伯格的任务是断定赛斯是否存在任何可能导致这些犯罪行为的减轻罪责的精神疾病. 格林伯格教授得出结论，没有足够的证据支持这一诊断.
The possibility that Seth had repressed post-traumatic stress disorder stemming from being trapped in the rubble of his family's hotel following the 1990 Luzon earthquake was also denied. Professor Greenberg stated that during pre-sentencing assessments, Seth told him, I was put on trial for being a lousy person. I have deep remorse for people I lied to, but they can't make me plead guilty to murder. At sentencing, Seth focused on his own suffering, telling his grandmother in court, If you don't think I'm feeling any pain, you're wrong. Whatever pain you're feeling, I am feeling it much worse than you. I'm not going to plead guilty to something I didn't do just to make people happy. On September 18, 2004, the day after his 24th birthday, Seth Gonzalez said emotionless in court as Justice Bruce James sentenced him to three concurrent life sentences without the possibility of parole. Judge James declared Seth lacked insight into the enormity of his offences and had failed to accept any responsibility for his crimes.
赛斯可能因1990年吕宋岛地震后被困在家族酒店废墟中而患有压抑性创伤后应激障碍的可能性也被否定了. 格林伯格教授表示，在量刑前的评估中，赛斯对他说：“我因为是个糟糕的人而被推上法庭. 我对被我欺骗过的人深感懊悔，但他们不能强迫我承认谋杀罪.”在宣刑时，赛斯将焦点放在自己的痛苦上，他在法庭上对祖母说：“如果你认为我没有感到任何痛苦，那你就错了. 无论你感受到什么痛苦，我都比你感受得更深. 我不会为了让别人高兴而承认我没有做过的事情.”2004年9月18日，在他24岁生日的第二天，赛斯·冈萨雷斯面无表情地坐在法庭上，听着布鲁斯·詹姆斯法官判处他终身监禁，共三项且同时执行，且不得假释. 詹姆斯法官宣告，赛斯缺乏对自己罪行严重性的认知，并且未能为自己的罪行承担任何责任.
Due to being found guilty of triple murder, Seth's lesser charge of threatening product contamination was dropped. Outside court, Seth's aunt Emily Luna said, It's actually a very sad day because we love Seth very much, but I'm just glad it's all over as well. We will always love him. Three years later, in June 2007, the New South Wales Supreme Court granted Seth approval to appeal his conviction, Based on the fact that he was not cautioned by police on the night of the murders, and therefore statements taken from him may have been deemed inadmissible. But the appeal was eventually dismissed and his convictions were upheld, on the basis that there had been no evidence that a miscarriage of justice had occurred. To this day, Seth continues to protest his innocence. His concurrent life sentences mean he will remain in jail for the rest of his life.
由于被判犯有三项谋杀罪，赛斯面临的较轻的威胁产品污染指控被撤销. 法庭外，赛斯的姑姑艾米丽·露娜说：“这其实是一个非常悲伤的日子，因为我们非常爱赛斯，但我同时也很高兴这一切都结束了. 我们永远都会爱他.”三年后，即2007年6月，新南威尔士州最高法院批准赛斯对定罪提出上诉，理由是警方在谋杀当晚没有对他进行警告，因此从他那里获取的供词可能被视为不可采纳. 但该上诉最终被驳回，定罪维持不变，理由是没有证据表明发生了司法不公. 直到今天，赛斯仍在坚称自己无罪. 他同时执行的终身监禁意味着他将在监狱中度过余生.
In November 2005, the former Gonzalez home on Collins Street was finally sold for $720,000 to a buyer who was fully aware and accepting of its dark history. In 2017, the owners of the former Gonzalez homestead spoke publicly about life in the house, saying they had a very good feeling about the property from the moment they walked inside. After many happy years spent creating their own memories inside the home, one of the owners told Woman's Day magazine, This is my home. I get really annoyed when people ask about what happened here because it happened before us. I know the Gonzaleses were a good family and would have liked to know we've taken over their home and been very happy here. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
2005年11月，科林斯街前冈萨雷斯住宅最终以72万澳元的价格出售给了一位完全知晓并接受其黑暗历史的买家. 2017年，前冈萨雷斯宅邸的主人公开谈到了在这栋房子里的生活，称他们从走进去的那一刻起，对这处房产就有着非常好的感觉. 在房子里度过了许多充满欢乐、创造自己回忆的岁月后，其中一位主人对《女性日》杂志说：“这是我的家. 每当有人问起这里发生过什么时，我都会感到很烦恼，因为那是发生在我们之前的事. 我知道冈萨雷斯一家是个好家庭，如果他们知道我们接管了他们的家并且在这里过得很开心，他们一定会很高兴的.”本集目前还没有评论. 点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论.